Ich bin dieses Kabel und dieses Kabel. Achso, jetzt ist es ganz weg. Jetzt habe ich zumindest Qualitätsrauschen und mich selbst. Und du?
Ich höre dich immer noch und mich selber schon ein bisschen.
Du könntest, glaube ich, das Mikro wieder noch ein bisschen besser ausrichten.
Wie ist das nochmal? So?
Das ist ein 90 Grad Winkel. Diese Fläche muss auf deinen Mund zeigen.
Aber die Fläche ist drin, wo ganz anders ist.
Ja, jetzt zeigst du quasi auf deine Wange.
So? So?
Ja, ist besser.
Du hast einfach zu viel Bart im Weg.
Ja, es wird manchmal immer schlimmer.
Mal schauen, wie weit es noch geht.
Nimmst du irgendwie Bartmittel oder sowas?
Ich habe gemerkt, wenn ich mir die Haare
oben jetzt immer so schön kurz rasiere,
dann hat man da weniger Pflegeaufwand,
aber mit längerem Bart umso mehr
dort. Das ist ein bisschen nervig.
Ich habe immer so ein Bartöl gekauft.
Ich sehe jetzt persönlich
nicht so den Riesenunterschied, aber vielleicht ist
einfach noch nicht lang genug dafür.
Ich kann dir nur sagen, wie man den Pflegeaufwand
sehr, sehr gering hält.
dann ziehst du es einfach ab oder machst nichts.
Ja.
Obwohl, da musst du dich regelmäßig rasieren,
ist auch doof. Oder du machst es
wie ich, du hast einfach keinen Bartwuchs.
Das ist halt einfach nur eine Frage der Zeit. Ich habe auch so
zwei Stellen, wo es halt weniger wächst.
Das sieht man aber nach einer Zeit nicht mehr, wenn
genug Bart da ist. Das ist so der Trick an der
Sache. Du warst es einfach noch länger.
Noch länger warten?
Noch länger warten. Sieht zwischendurch echt scheiße aus.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist wie wenn du von null
anfängst, dir die Haare lang wachsen zu lassen. Da hast du
so eine In-Between-Geschichte die ganze Zeit.
einen Monat lang mindestens daheim einsperren
und mal nicht sozialisieren und danach ist alles prima.
Vielleicht im Winter.
Dass es nicht irgendwie so
untenrum Mützen gibt.
Das nennt sich Hosen.
Nein, nicht so weit unten rum.
Ich meine so Kopf unten rum.
Wow.
Und auch Mützen ist auch ein guter Sinn.
Das nennt sich Schal.
Ha.
Oder Schleier.
Tatsächlich, das geht so in die Richtung.
Oder wenn du dir einfach so einen Mundschutz nach unten ziehst.
Skimaske.
Du kannst ja aber nicht mit einer Skimaske so durch den Alltag gehen.
Vor allem, wenn du Geld abheben gehst in der Bank.
Kommt halt ein bisschen schräg.
Ich hätte gerne 500 Euro abgehoben.
Hier, da haben sie alles.
In einem unmarkierten Schein.
Ich habe sonst immer unmarkierte Scheine bekommen.
Oh Mann.
Du, Kieran, was ist eigentlich die Vorwahl von Berlin?
Keinem das Schimmer.
eins.
Nee, keine Ahnung, wieso.
Schau mal nach.
Hey Siri, was ist denn
die Vorwahl von
Berlin? Type to Siri hier.
Ich habe im Internet folgendes zu
denn die Vorwahl von Berlin gefunden.
Ja, mir wollte ich schon fragen, warum schreibst du denn damit rein?
Das wird ja garantiert nicht rausfiltern.
Oh, was ist die Vorwahl von Berlin?
Was ist die Vorwahl von Berlin?
Ich hab's übrigens schon mal in unser Pad gepackt.
Das hier hab ich gefunden.
Ich hab ein paar Weblinks.
Wie triggert mein Siri, glaube ich,
nicht das, was du triggern möchtest?
Warte mal, ich probier's mal aus.
Was?
Hey Siri, what's the area code for Berlin, Germany?
The answer I found is 030.
Ich verstehe den Witz nicht.
Ah, gut, okay.
Also.
Das ist der Witz hier.
Hi, Kian.
Hi, Hendrik.
Willkommen zur Akronomisierbar-Folge 030.
Ah, jetzt.
Oh, Mann.
Okay, danke.
Tja, wir sind in den 30ern.
Jetzt wird das Verstehen von Witzen alles ein bisschen schwieriger.
Ein riesiges Bedummt.
Okay, verstehe.
Folge 30 sind wir jetzt.
Also ich muss mich an dieser Stelle nochmal bei unseren Hörern entschuldigen,
weil wir haben gerade bei Sascha, der bestimmt zwischendurch noch zwei Dienstreisen ohne Podcast gemacht hat.
Ich will mir das jetzt immer referenzieren.
Weil die letzte Folge haben wir aufgenommen und dann habe ich die auch wie zwei Wochen ungeschnitten
auf meinem Rechner mindestens rumgeschleppt, weil ich irgendwie unter der Woche nicht dazu gekommen bin,
das nachzubearbeiten.
Und dann war ich eine Woche zelten, spontan, sehr spontan, über Pfingsten.
Wo warst du?
Ach, ganz banal.
Schulfreund hatte mich angeschrieben, hey du, ich habe jetzt hier meinen Jahresurlaub genommen, was machst du über Pfingsten?
Ich so, keine Ahnung.
Und der so, ja, wollen wir einfach Zelten fahren?
Und dann sind wir irgendwie, du hast hier Zelten gefahren, ganz banal.
Du hast sie.
Nice.
Genau, sind so nach Rostock hochgehetzt.
Ich habe mir noch ein Zelt besorgt.
Ach, okay.
Ich habe bestimmt zwölf Jahre lang das gleiche Zelt gehabt.
Das war mit mir auf Festivals, das war mit mir mehrmals Zelten irgendwo in der Wildnis.
Das habe ich zum Trampen mitgenommen.
Krass, das habe ich nach dem Abi zum Zelten mitgenommen.
Anyway, das war irgendwann defekt und dann dachte ich mir, kaufe ich mir so ein ähnliches nochmal.
Dann war das spontan.
Irgendwie Mittwoch fragte er mich, wollen wir dieses Wochenende zum Zelten gehen?
Und er so, ich so, ja, aber hast du ein Zelt?
Nee, ich könnte mal gucken.
In dem Moment dachte ich, vielleicht bestelle ich mir das einfach mal eins.
Und dann bin ich an dem Freitag, eigentlich wollte ich Freitag schon hochfahren.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, nee, komm erst Samstag.
Ich muss nämlich noch bis Freitag 18 Uhr noch was im Büro bleiben.
weil ich es mir immer ins Büro liefern lasse.
Und dann kam wirklich irgendwie
18 Uhr noch was das Zelt an.
Er hat geliefert an der Tür.
Und dann wollte ich ihm gerade schreiben,
ich habe jetzt das Zelt.
In dem Moment sehe ich in dem Messenger,
mit dem wir dort immer schreiben.
Ich glaube, das ist in dem Fall WhatsApp gewesen.
So, ich habe jetzt zwei Zelte von einem Freund ausgeliehen.
Ich habe sie schon mal bei mir im Innenhof aufgebaut.
Du kannst sie dir mal angucken.
Und ich so, das ist schön, wir nehmen jetzt mein Zelt.
Nice.
Und dann war das nächste Wochenende, war BRN?
Ah, stimmt, das war ja auch noch in der Zwischenzeit.
Warst du da? Nur mal kurz zwischendurch.
Ich hatte dieses Jahr nicht so wirklich Bock
hinzugehen. Wir haben es mal angeschaut.
Ich muss zumindest eine Koller
auf der BRN trinken, nehme ich mir immer vor.
Stimmt, wir hatten uns ja getroffen sogar.
Stimmt, stimmt. Zufällig da am Dings,
am Fiasko.
Am Fiasko, genau. Da, wo Julius Berndt
gespielt hat. Warst du schon mal am Fiasko? Nö.
Ich muss jedes Mal an den Mikrokörnel denken,
wenn ich den Namen von der Kneipe sehe.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die da...
viel drüber diskutieren.
Also für mich haben irgendwie
Dynamo Dresden und Mikrokörner sehr viel miteinander
zu tun.
Das haben bestimmt schon viele Leute festgestellt.
Aber das liegt bei mir auch eher
persönlich daran, dass der Björn vom
Betriebssystem Lehrstuhl mich zweimal irgendwie
zu Dynamo-Spielen mitgenommen hat.
Der hatte irgendwie Dauerkarten für einen K-Block.
Und auch einen K-Block.
Cool.
Wenn man Bock drauf hat. Das ist nicht so meins.
Also BRN kann man sich echt mal antun.
Alle unsere nicht Dresden noch zuhörer.
nächstes Jahr, heute in einem Jahr
BRN ist, ja, vielleicht vor drei
Wochen in einem Jahr BRN ist,
dann geht da mal hin.
Das ist irgendwie ein Stadtteilfestival in Dresden.
Das ist ziemlich krass. Ja, das ist eine ziemlich coole Geschichte,
wenn man das mal auf Wikipedia nachschlägt,
wie die BRN so entstanden ist und was das in den ersten Jahren
so war. Kannst du das nachvollziehen?
Ich habe nur diesen Mikronationsteil im Kopf jetzt spontan,
aber sonst würde ich es auch nochmal nachschlagen.
Genau, deswegen heißt es ja Bunte Republik Neustadt.
Ja, genau. Und es ging damit los,
dass sie sich nach der Wende irgendwie eingezäunt hatten
und gesagt haben, wir rufen unseren eigenen Staat aus
und die Flagge ist irgendwie die Deutschlandflagge mit einer
Mickey-Maus obendrauf. Genau, eigene Pässe hier noch
entstanden, eigene Währung.
Genau.
Seitdem ist es eigentlich nur eskaliert und es ist halt so ein
ganz normales Stadtteilfest, wie es in Dresden noch fünf andere
gibt, aber es ist halt die gesamte
Neustadt. Das ist riesig. Das ist
mit Abstand das größte Stadtteilfest, das ich je gesehen habe.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also Stadtteilfest.
Beim Stadtteilfest denkt man sich, das ist ja diese eine Straße
runter mit so ein paar Läden, wo so Kinder ihr altes Spielzeug
verkaufen und ein paar Leute Bier ausschenken.
Wie viel? 10.000 Leute unterwegs ist der Bär?
20, 30, 40, irgendwie sowas. Krass groß.
Ja, und der Schulfreund, mit dem ich Zelten fahre,
den hatte ich schon ein paar Jahre eigentlich
so wirklich gesehen. Da habe ich gesagt,
wenn du nächste Woche noch Urlaub hast und nichts
zu tun hast, kommen wir einfach mal nach Dresden
und wir gehen mal auf die BRN zusammen.
Und er hat sich auch gedacht,
Stadtteilfest, so haben wir auch bei uns hier in Rostock,
aber BRN ist halt was anderes.
Das ist schon cool, gerade wenn man es nicht gewöhnt ist.
Wenn man es halt hier erkennt, dann ist es halt,
ich weiß nicht, irgendwie so ein bisschen das Besondere.
Anfangs fand ich es sehr, sehr cool.
Mittlerweile ist es so, abends will ich da nicht mehr sein.
Du hast sowieso eine andere Beziehung dazu,
weil du in der Neustadt da direkt an der Hauptstraße
geholt hast. Ja, also es ging.
Ein Jahr war mal richtig scheiße, aber
ansonsten es ging. Es war jetzt nicht
so kritisch schlimm oder so.
Ich fand es witzig vom Timing her,
dass gleichzeitig auch noch die Kiff in Dresden
war, die 47.
Diese Konferenz der Informatik-Fachschaften.
Stimmt, die habe ich nur wieder verpasst, von der habe ich bloß auf Twitter
gelesen. Warst du da? Ich war zumindest
im ASCII ein paar Mal
so 23 bis 3 Uhr
Frühschichten besetzen,
weil es sonst keiner gemacht hat.
Aber war richtig witzig.
KIF ist ja quasi wie so ein Mini-Congress,
wo einfach nur so komische Informatikstudenten
und Ehemalige rumlaufen.
Witzig.
Ich wäre da auch eigentlich hingegangen.
Das sah eigentlich witzig aus.
Aber ich finde es witzig getimt,
weil es halt gleichzeitig Überschneidung hatte
mit der LNDW, mit der Langnacht der Wissenschaften
und dann auch der BRN.
Sprich, wenn die sich mal noch ein bisschen Dresden angeschaut haben,
dann war halt erstaunlich viel los spontan in diesen paar Tagen.
Das finde ich eigentlich am traurigsten,
dass die LNDW sich schon seit Jahren
das gleiche Wochenende mit der BRN teilt.
Also ich war jetzt immer hin und her gerissen,
wo ich hingehen sollte.
Ich bin in den letzten Jahren immer freitags noch zur LNDW gegangen.
Die ist ja halt nur den einen Abend.
Genau.
Und diesmal habe ich mir gedacht,
ich gehe zur BRN.
Da war ich quasi Freitag, Samstag, Sonntag,
weil ich halt mit meinem Kumpel da war.
Das war eigentlich wie Festival.
An der Lutherkirche sind auch richtig gute Bands gewesen.
Da gibt es so geiles Essen.
So einen richtig geilen,
So ein Fladenbrot
gefüllt mit, weiß ich schon gar nicht mehr.
Sag jetzt nicht Langosch.
Nee, ich habe mit so
Hummus drin und irgendwie was anderes.
Das war richtig lecker.
Vielleicht hier von Fatima, kann das sein?
Kannst du Fatima?
Auf der
Nürnberger Straße ist so ein kleiner Laden von
ich glaube, die ist Syrerin
oder sowas.
Die macht so Raps und so syrisches Essen.
Super geil.
Wo ist der Nürnberger?
Das wäre jetzt fast so die Ecke hier, wo man
jetzt mal was essen gehen könnte.
Die haben jetzt nicht mehr auf dem Weg.
Nee, ich meine aber jetzt dadurch, dass ich ja jetzt hier in der Nähe wohne.
Ja, Nürnberger ist es nicht direkt.
Das ist da Nürnberger
EI direkt.
Das ist doch noch umso näher bei mir.
Ist es?
Ich weiß nicht, wo es die Dings vor hat.
Egal, wir müssen jetzt das nicht im Podcast berießen.
Apropos, während wir bei Dingen sind,
die in Dresden sind.
Ich bin gestern an einem
entstehenden Bitcoin ATM in der Neustadt
vorbeigefahren. Du hast das
Foto gepostet. Das hat mich ja sehr
schockiert, dass Leute sowas jetzt
noch aufmachen, aber anscheinend sind
die ja begeistert. Ich habe irgendwie noch
so ein paar Euro wert Bitcoin auf dem
Telefon, wo jedes Mal, wenn ich mein Telefon neu starte
und diese App im Hintergrund angeht,
die mir irgendwie so ein Pop-Up produziert. Vorsicht, du hast ja noch Geld auf.
Das ist die Schildbach-App, die da drin ist. Genau, genau.
Und dann hat mir irgendjemand auf Twitter
gepostet, ja,
Bitcoin skyrocketed
gerade und dann habe ich mal geguckt, wie viel
diese paar Euro noch sind. Das sind mittlerweile 30 Euro
oder sowas. Davon hätte ich irgendwie vor
ein paar Wochen Kinematik kaufen können.
Ja, das sind gerade bei 11.000 Dollar, glaube ich, der Kurs.
Das ist unwahrscheinlich.
Selbst jetzt
hätte es sich gelohnt, vor fünf Wochen
ein paar Bitcoin gekauft zu haben.
Also ein paar Micro-Bitcoins, zumindest so
ein paar hundert Euro investiert zu haben.
Es hätte sich auch gelohnt, ein paar Bitcoin gekauft zu haben.
Ja, ja, lass uns nicht drüber reden.
Das sind so die Sachen, die ich bis zum Ende
meines Lebens bereue. Es ist halt wie mit jedem Aktienkurs
so. Ich habe auch mit Bitcoin
Spaß gehabt, waren wir das 2010, 11 rum
irgendwann so, immer 12.
im Studium. Das war cool,
aber so immer so, ja, da kannst du gar kein Geld reinstecken.
Und es ist halt heutzutage auch so eine Währung,
die hat halt zu viele negative
Konnotationen noch mit dran. Da fällt mir irgendwie
ein Film ein von Anfang der
2000er, wo einer zurück in der Zeit reist
und dann seinen Sohn trifft
oder eigentlich selbst ein Jünger trifft oder
irgend sowas und dann sagt...
Ich suche nach geraumer
Zeit nach so einem ähnliches Film.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der hieß.
und ich weiß bloß, der Witz war,
dass der zu dem sagt, pass auf, wenn du
eine Sache dir merken willst, dann merke
dir Yahoo.
Du willst heute noch nicht wissen, was es
heißt, aber merke dir eins
Yahoo.
Kauf das einfach.
Das ist ein Witz, der nicht
wirklich gut gealtert ist.
Heutzutage weiß kein Mensch mehr, was zum Gehör ist.
Ja klar, beim Wissen tut man es schon noch.
Man weiß es noch, aber
jemand, der jetzt vielleicht
18 ist, weiß ich nicht mehr, was Yahoo ist.
Das glaube ich schon. Also genauso wie Kinder
von heute noch nicht vergessen haben, was
Disketten oder Kassetten sind. Das glaube ich
einfach nicht.
Aber genauso
schlecht werden diese Bitcoin-Witze altern.
In 10,
15 Jahren. Was ich eigentlich zu Bitcoin
erzählen wollte, ist, ich habe dann auf mein Telefon
geguckt und hatte plötzlich 30 Euro wert Bitcoin auf dem Handy.
Es waren vielleicht vorher,
was weiß ich, keine Ahnung, 1 Euro oder sowas.
Und dann wollte ich damit meine
E-Mail-Anbieter bezahlen, weil den kannst du mit Bitcoin bezahlen.
Und dann gehe ich da drauf
und dann ist es irgendwie mit BitPay
und dann steht da, kannst du das mit Bitcoin
bezahlen oder du kannst jetzt hier mit Bitcoin
Cash bezahlen.
Und ich habe echt
beides mehrmals ausprobiert, das hat meine Bezahlung
nicht angenommen.
Bitcoin Cash ist eine andere Währung, die kannst du ja gar nicht einfach so nutzen.
Genau.
Also es ist nicht kompatibel, es ist nicht das gleiche.
Genau, deswegen so tief habe ich gar nicht reingesteckt
Da habe ich gedacht, ja, ist das jetzt nur, nee, ist nicht dasselbe.
Na, da bezahle ich mal mit normal Bitcoin,
aber selbst das geht irgendwie nicht, das Protokoll ist.
Diese Schildbach-App ist mit diesem Care-Code nicht mehr.
Also kriegst du die ja irgendwie noch raus?
Keine Ahnung, ich kann wahrscheinlich
das alles nochmal manuell machen.
Im Prinzip brauchst du ja bloß den Private Key.
Vielleicht gehe ich einfach in diese Bude hin,
da in der Neustadt.
Die helfen dir bestimmt.
Ja, hey, ich habe noch diese alten Bitcoins,
wollte mir die vielleicht.
Ich hätte gerne dieses 30 Euro aus meinem Handy rausgeben.
Das sind bestimmt so Leute,
die vorher auch bloß so Handy-Reparaturen gemacht haben.
Ja, ich hätte gerne meine Kontakte von dem Telefon
auf das Telefon übertragen.
Das ist auch noch so ein Service von solchen Leuten,
die den Akku austauschen,
das Display reparieren oder sowas.
Ergutzt ein bisschen, weil vorher war da so ein richtig cooler Döner-Mann drin.
Sams hieß der.
Der hieß Faddy, glaube ich.
Der Typ war so cool.
Der freundlichste Typ, den ich da je gesehen habe.
Generell super cooler Typ.
Und der hat so geile Döner gehabt.
Einfach nur mit gebratenem Gemüse.
Die waren mega.
Und der hat irgendwann wieder zugemacht.
Und jetzt ist ein Bitcoin-ATM in dem
seinem Laden drin. Ist richtig traurig.
Aber naja, was will man machen?
Irgendwo müssen diese
Leute ja auch ihr Geld loswerden.
Tja, jetzt musst du dich halt mit den Dönern hier
an diesem anderen Stadtteil...
Der Samse sehe ich schon länger mit dazu.
Schade.
Ich hatte die Dinger extra aus dem Büro mitgenommen
und dann habe ich sie vergessen, auf den Tisch zu legen.
Ich sagte, du kriegst da vielleicht noch einen Kick
raus. Ich habe mir so Untersetzer geholt.
Floppy-Coaster.
Oh, schade, die gehen ja
gar nicht.
Dafür gehen es auch nicht kaputt.
Das stimmt.
Schaut mal, die meinen Floppy-Laufwerk nicht hier reinschieben.
Das ist das China-Gadget der
Woche.
Das sind
3,5
Zoll-Disketten aus Silikon
als Untersetzer. Gibt es in
nur in schwarz und in vierfarbig.
Wir legen das hier 1,4 MB drauf.
aufgepasst haben. Das ist krass, ne?
Diese rauen Datenmengen.
Ich habe auch neulich irgendwo den Begriff
Floppycast gelesen. Hast du das
gesehen? Nee.
Irgendwie in meinem Podcatcher.
Floppycast hieß das so? Was ist das?
Das waren Podcasts, die auf eine Floppy-Diskette
passen. Och geil.
Ich meine, im Prinzip können wir unseren Podcast
auch so runterrechnen, dass er passt, aber
ich weiß ja nicht, was die Qualität
dann... Ich kann das mal probieren.
Was da hörbar bei rauskommt. Das wird eventuell
mit hier Multipass,
Opus auf
12k oder sowas.
Du kannst es auch in jedem beliebigen anderen
Format auf die Größe pressen, aber
dann ist es halt am Ende halt scheiße.
Es wäre mal spannend, ob man unsere Stimmen noch auseinanderhalten
kann, wenn ich es auf
eine Diskettengröße runter komprimiere.
Das müsste eigentlich gehen. Probier mal.
Das kann ich mal irgendwie hinterher ausprobieren.
Je nachdem, wie lang diese Folge ist.
Die letzte Folge war ja sehr lang. So ein kurzes Soundbite
von dem 1,4
1,4 MB Compressed Pfeil
dann mal hier so rein schneiden, wenn das geht.
Ja, das probiere ich mal aus.
Sehr cool.
Aber ich habe irgendwie vor
Jahren als Schüler mal mit
unterschiedlichen Videokompressionsverfahren
rumgespielt. Also ich habe mal mit
MP3 rumgespielt.
Oder meinst du Audio?
Nee, Audio rumgespielt.
Mit Videokompressionsverfahren habe ich das ganze Spaß
selber DVDs retten.
Das ist so
zeitaufwürdig.
Das waren noch Zeiten.
Das hat überhaupt keinen Spaß gemacht.
Und heutzutage, ich habe nicht mal mehr
CD-Laufwerk irgendwo gerade.
Ich habe eins in irgendeiner Kiste rumliegen, das ich
alle paar Jahre mal auspacke.
In der Schublade neben dem Schreibtisch.
Ich brauche immer, wenn ich Passfotos machen gehe,
weil die kriege ich immer auf einer CD mit.
Cool.
Da ist so ein Datenträger in der Hand.
Was jetzt?
Dieses Medium ist auch echt mittlerweile tot.
Ja, komplett.
Ich sehe noch manchmal, auf der Straße siehst du Musiker rumstehen.
Das ist eigentlich schade, weil auf der Straße siehst du Musiker rumstehen
oder du bist bei Konzerten von kleinen Bands.
die geben dir dann CDs mit und du denkst dir, das ist jetzt cool,
ich nehme jetzt mal eine mit, aber ich weiß nicht, wenn ich die damit machen soll.
Mittlerweile bezahlbar genug ist da einfach
Flash Drives auszugeben.
Vielleicht, aber das Problem
mit Flash Drives, ja, wenn dann SD-Karten,
aber da hat nicht mehr jedem, das ist mit dem USB
ist ja geil, das mit dem USB
ist geil, weil es wird mittelfristig nicht weggehen,
obwohl es ist ja jetzt quasi
schon der Zeitpunkt, wo es stirbt, also du musst jetzt
USB-C-Sticks verteilen, um ein bisschen
zukunftstauglich zu sein. Und die wird es vielleicht auch nicht mehr geben.
Ich schätze mal, USB-C wird wahrscheinlich das letzte sein,
womit du noch deinen
Staubsauger aufladen kannst, oder?
Also das zukunftsträchtigste ist
nach wie vor jetzt. Ich habe nicht gesagt Staubsauger betreiben, sondern Staubsauger
aufladen.
Zukunftsträchtigste ist wahrscheinlich die URL.
Aber das Problem mit USB ist ja, dass du dich nicht traust,
das an ein Gerät ranzustecken, weil USB könnte ja
prinzipiell alles sein. Das könnte ja gleichzeitig
anfangen, irgendwie wie wild
Tastenanschläge an deinen Rechner zu schicken.
Das ist eigentlich witzig, dass ich so eine Logik nicht auf eine CD
packen kann. Das ging.
Windows hat alles ausgeführt, was Setup-Exe hieß.
Irgendwas Ausführbares, klar, so Auto-Boot, Auto-Run-Krams, wie immer das hieß nochmal.
Da gehen schon Dinge.
Aber klar, die Angst hat niemand bei einem optischen Datenträger.
Dann hätte ich lieber von dem Musiker vielleicht so einen QR-Code mitgegeben oder einen Papierzettel mit einer URL.
Eine URL ist das einzige, was halt wirklich zukunftstauglich aktuell ist.
Aber Google wollte eigentlich auch die URLs
abschaffen.
Da gab es mal irgendwie
Google. Einfach alles über Shortlinks
bei Google, da kommt gleich irgendwas oder was.
Wie heißt denn das?
Deprecaten? Ich suche gerade das Schlappwort.
URLs deprecaten.
Ich habe ja auch noch eine Frage, wie lange
die Seite dahinter lebt.
Und wenn das dann auch auf irgendeinem Provider-Host ist,
wie keine Ahnung, eine Facebook-Seite,
eine MySpace-Seite damals wieder.
Hatten wir das letzte Mal schon über diesen schönen Partei-Urgain
URL-Shorten angerettet.
Du meinst FCK, AfD? Ich glaube, den hat man angesprochen.
Genau.
Naja, ich finde es jetzt nicht mehr.
Aber es ist noch so passiert. Ich war zwischendurch eigentlich noch
das erste Wochenende, nachdem wir die letzte Folge aufgenommen haben,
war ich in Berlin
auf der JS-Conf.
Stimmt. Wie war die so?
Das war ziemlich witzig. Es war angeblich
die letzte JS-Conf, die zehnte und letzte.
Die wollen das nicht mehr machen, die Leute, die es so organisieren.
Okay, krass. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass einfach
jemand anders eine andere Konferenz in dem
Spektrum machen wird. Irgendwas wird die Interessenten abholen.
Es gibt in Deutschland zumindest noch den JS-Kongress, der ist dann in München, war ich auch schon mal.
Der wird wahrscheinlich weitergehen, aber die JS-Konfläute haben das jetzt zehnmal gemacht und haben dann keine Lust mehr.
Vielleicht macht das entweder nächstes Jahr jemand anders oder es gibt halt man jahrlang keine Konferenz.
Und ja, das war lustig.
Wir sind so ein bisschen rumgegangen, ich war mit einem Kollegen da, mit dem ich auch schon beim JS-Kongress war.
Und wir sind dann einfach so die Stände abgegangen
mit den einzelnen...
Da waren Leute von Mozilla da,
waren Leute von Google da.
Mehrere Stände von Google direkt.
Das ist ja die Internetfirma.
Der Stand von Chrome war leider nicht so gut besetzt.
Okay.
Die haben sich auch ein bisschen höher umgeschaut.
Dafür war ein Riesenstand von Microsoft da,
die irgendwie einen Edge-Stand hatten.
Das war dann der Chrome-Stand.
Deswegen habe ich auch diesen Edge Canary-Sticker
jetzt auf meinem Laptop.
Da kennst du kaum, was das sein soll,
wenn du es nicht weißt.
Wir hatten das letzte Mal schon drüber geredet, dass
Edge jetzt auf Chrome basiert ist und dass man ziemlich scharf
hingucken muss, um zu
sehen, dass es nicht Chrome ist. Aber tatsächlich
ist es auch so, dass die, glaube ich, noch nicht viel gemacht haben.
Die haben halt aus Chromium noch ein bisschen Chrome interner
rausgeschmissen, Google interner rausgeschmissen.
Wenn auf die History-Seite
von Edge geht, sieht
eins zu eins genauso aus wie die von Chrome.
Die haben einfach ein bisschen CSS angepasst.
Ich schätze mal, dass sie noch mehr machen werden.
Das Projekt muss sicherlich
auch erstmal Fahrt aufnehmen.
Genau. Der eine von den
Tech-Leads, der dafür
als Vertretung
von dem Edge-Team in Berlin war,
war der Haupt-Maintainer von
Webpack. Okay. Also die haben
sich schon ein paar Leute da irgendwie zusammengeholt.
Die ganz gut sind.
Das ist ganz witzig.
Und ja, es gab ein paar coole Vorträge.
Einer hat so einen relativ guten Vortrag
über die...
Der Vortrag selber war eigentlich nicht so gut
gemacht, aber keine Ahnung,
aber der war trotzdem witzig. Der hat einen Vortrag
über die Web-Audio-API gemacht
und wie er sich seine eigenen Gitarneffekte
in JavaScript gebaut hat.
Und das war
wirklich gut aufgearbeitet mit,
na, wenn du hier ein Echo machen möchtest, dann musst du
den in den in den reinpipen.
Ich glaube, Echo war echt das schwierigste oder Hall war das
schwierigste Effekt. Und dann irgendwie für Verzerrung
brauchst du das und für so und so.
Und dann schreibst du diesen dreizeiligen Funktionsaufruf,
den du irgendwie in diesen
Audio-Worker mit reingibst oder sowas.
Der war echt gut, der Vertrag. Das Problem war, dass
der unbedingt noch zeigen musste, dass er
ein bisschen Gitarre spielen kann. Deswegen hat er halt
direkt mit der Gitarre auf die Bühne
gekommen und hat dann halt so Live-Crolling-mäßig
die Effekte programmiert, während er da eine Gitarre
gespielt hat. Das war eigentlich ganz geil.
Das ist ein witziges Demo.
So richtig gut Gitarre spielen konnte er nicht.
Ah, schade.
Das war ziemlich cool. Was war noch?
Ein Vortrag war von
einem der Hauptentwickler von
Adblock Plus.
Ah, okay.
Über
Adblock
und Adblocking, Circumventions,
so Techniken, die so
die Werbeindustrie so
an den Tag legt, um irgendwie ihre Werbung zu
platzieren, sodass die Blocker das nicht rausfiltern
können. Irgendwie ganz viel so
Pseudo-Code erzeugst oder Pseudo-DOM
erzeugst, wo
ganz viel Rauschen ist, aber du siehst nur
die Hälfte davon und es ist halt auf unterschiedliche Art und
Weisen so gestylt, dass dann
viele Sachen dazwischen einfach wieder
weg sind und dann trotzdem dein Ad-Text
irgendwo lesbar ist.
Das ist ganz gruselig, einen Vortrag
empfehlen.
Es war ein Vortrag
über
GraphQL dabei,
wie man
ein GraphQL Backend in JavaScript baut
und da war ziemlich gut erklärt,
dass zu GraphQL eigentlich gar nicht so viel dazugehört.
Also wie das Lookup
gebaut wird und wie diese Queries
verarbeitet werden und auf deiner Datenstruktur
mappt, war ziemlich gut nachvollziehbar.
Ich krieg's jetzt aus dem Stehgreif gar nicht mehr so gut
reproduziert.
Das klingt gut. Aber kann ich empfehlen.
Einer hat einen Vortrag, den habe ich leider verpasst, den habe ich jetzt
vor ein paar Tagen nochmal
online geguckt. Einer hat einen Vortrag gehalten
darüber, wie er sich seine eigene JavaScript-Engine
in Rust geschrieben hat.
Natürlich. Was auch sonst.
Und es
gibt mindestens drei neue Paketmanager.
Mindestens.
Die eine Maintenerin von NPM hat
einen Vortrag gehalten über
den neuen Nachfolger von NPM.
Es gibt einen Nachfolger? Ja, die arbeiten
an einem neuen, der heißt Tink.
Und der heißt, warum anders und es ist nicht einfach der neue NPM-Version?
Und der ist so lange experimentell,
bis er nicht mehr experimentell ist und dann ist er NPM 8.
Ah, okay.
Und da gibt es irgendwie, die arbeiten alle
irgendwie an unterschiedlichen Techniken.
Ist der NPM 7 schon?
Nee.
Ich verstehe, die warten einfach noch ein bisschen weiter damit.
Ja, manchmal, wenn du so einen ganz krassen Sprung machst
und du eh ständig so Major-Version-Updates hast
und die nichts mehr bedeuten dadurch,
gibt es manchmal, dass Leute
so Major-Versionen überspringen.
Das ist doch dumm.
Es gibt kein...
Wo sie einfach zu doof waren,
die Media-Versions aber zu abgehören.
Ja, Windows ist eh was anderes. Aber es gibt
kein OnePlus 4.
Es gab nach dem 3
kam direkt die 5, weil die 4
im asiatischen Unglückszahl ist.
Ach Gott, okay.
Winamp 5.
Ich hab Winamp...
Es gab Winamp 2X
irgendwas, zig Versionen bis
Winamp 2.75.
Dann haben sie sich gedacht,
wir machen jetzt mal, ist jetzt cool,
ist es schließlich 2001. Wir machen
jetzt mal ein komplett neu gebautes
Winamp und da hattest du so mit
Vektorgrafiken, du konntest
übelst krasse animierte Themes oben drauf packen,
wo du nicht mehr einfach so ein quadratisches...
Da kamen das erst, diese geilen Winamp-Themes.
Genau. Und das war ein kompletter Rewrite
von Winamp und der
hat überhaupt nicht performt.
Das war Winamp 3 und das ging dann
so mehr schlecht als recht und irgendwann hat sich
gedacht, das geht
irgendwie nicht, wir müssen das jetzt anders machen. Und dann haben sie
quasi dieses Theming-Ding einfach in
2 wieder rausgebracht und haben das Winamp 5
genommen.
Jetzt, wo ich drüber nachdenke, es ist halt genau Winamp 2
plus Winamp 3.
Ah!
Oh Gott.
Wahrscheinlich sollten wir einfach auch die 30 überspringen. Machen wir direkt jetzt
akronomisieren wir mal 40. Nein, nein, da passt der Witz doch gar nicht.
Ich kann nächstes Mal Folge 40
weitermachen, immer noch die Major-Version inkommentieren.
Also das ist irgendwie der...
Folge 131.
Warum nicht?
Zumindest haben sich die ganzen...
Wenn wir schon drei Zahlen zu nummerieren müssen, können wir das Major-Miner-Patch nehmen.
Stimmt. Das hat hier
der Changelog lange gemacht.
Echt? Die haben
quasi
einfach Punkte zwischen die Zahlen
gemacht. Nice.
Das haben wir gerade akkognizieren
Version 0.3.0. Genau.
Das war auch doof, weil nach der
2.9 nicht logischerweise die
3.0 folgen musste. Ja doch, wir machen
jetzt ein bisschen was anderes, deswegen haben wir hier
einen API-Change.
Sehr regelmäßige
Version-Bumps hier. Also
sondern die Art der Inkrementierung
immer exakt neun Patch-Versionen
bis zum nächsten meiner...
Es gibt Leute, die machen das einfach so.
Also nach
TypeScript 2.9
kam einfach TypeScript 3 raus.
Warum?
Ich glaube auch, Microsoft hat das eventuell mit den Versionen
noch nicht so richtig verstanden.
Ist mir ja auch egal, warum die versionieren.
Also nochmal Tink.
Ah, stimmt, da war man.
Du kennst ja diese Grafik mit
hier
Neutronenstern,
schwarzes Loch,
Node-Modules.
Und die haben sich halt jetzt,
überlegen sich alle, wie werden wir dieses Node-Modules-Verzeichnis
los? Und bei Tink ist es wohl so, dass du deine
Dependencies nicht in deinem Paket
installierst, in deinem Folder,
sondern dass du irgendwie
im System, in deinem Hauptverzeichnis
irgendwo zentral einfach deine
ganzen Versionen hinlegst. Da hast du dann
irgendwie, vielleicht heißt es da auch
Node-Modules oder Tink-Modules oder sowas.
Und da liegt dann Slash deine Dependency drunter, LeftPad.
Und unterhalb von LeftPad liegen dann die Ordner mit unterschiedlichen Versionen davon.
Und was Tink macht, ist, das guckt beim Laden von deinem Ding,
überlebt das quasi, wenn du es mit Node startest, dein Lookup.
Ich glaube darüber, dass das File-System-Modul so ein bisschen monkey-patchen.
Und dann wird das
Node-Module-Lookup
so revertet,
dass das nicht in deinem lokalen Node-Modules
Verzeichnis nachguckt, sondern es guckt in deine
Package-JSON nach deinen Dependencies und
mappt dir die irgendwie direkt in deine Binary rein.
Und das funktioniert, ohne dass die Dinger installiert
sind, denn wenn du dein
Skript einfach startest, dann werden die
wenn notwendig einfach runtergeladen,
wenn du es brauchst.
Wie kann das einfach alles funktionieren?
Das ist die Art und
Weise, wie Tink das machen will.
Der zweite Vortrag war dann...
Da passt übrigens sehr gut dieser Tweet von John Griffin dazu,
der eine neue React-App einfach mal
bauen wollte und hat, glaube ich,
10 direkte
Dependencies dazu genommen für Paketen, die er haben
wollte und hat
18.000 transitive Dependencies
in seinem Graph gehabt.
Dann kompiliert das runter und dann kommt
einfach bloß eine 100 Kilo
weiter. Das ist doch nicht okay,
sowas. Das ist doch gestört.
Aber okay.
Aber du fängst halt auch immer wieder bei Null an.
Du legst das nicht in deinem System ab,
wie bei, weiß ich nicht, Qt oder SwiftUI
oder was weiß ich.
Ich mach mal weiter. Das war,
wie Tink das machen will. Dann gab es irgendwie einen Vortrag
von dem Typen, der Jarn macht.
Da ging es um Jarn 2.0.
Und da überlegen sie auch, wie sie dieses Notmoduls
verzeichnend loswerden wollen. Da haben sie es allerdings
eher so gemacht, dass sie nicht das Lookup
ändern, sondern dass sie
die Art und Weise,
wie das
Da haben sie auch irgendwie so ein Vorlade-Dings.
Also wenn du dein Skript direkt von Jahren aus startest,
wird irgendwie etwas anderes gemanke-patcht.
Und dann legen die Dateien nicht,
das ist optional, nicht in deinem Notebook-Dirt-Verzeichnis,
sondern irgendwie in einem Punkt Jahren direkt auch in deinem Repo drin.
Und die Empfehlung von denen ist, dass du das mit eincheckst.
Aber warum nennt es dann Punkt Jahren?
Weil sie die Dateien nicht auspacken.
Sie ziehen es von,
sie ziehen es über eine bestimmte API von NPM
runter, ohne dass sie die TARS
auspacken, sodass es unausgepackt auf deiner
Platte liegt.
Weil das besser ist.
Ich empfehle, ich kriege es nicht mehr ganz zusammen, ich empfehle
die Vorträge dazu, ich packe die alle mal in die Shownotes rein.
Das war das.
Und der
dritte Vortrag dann war von
CJ Silverio,
die ist irgendwie Mitarbeiterin
bei NPM
Inc. gewesen, quasi bei der Firma NPM.
und ist da ausgestiegen
und hat einen Vortrag darüber gehalten, der hieß
Wie eine Sekte, wo man so
Ja, quasi. Die hat einen ziemlich coolen Vortrag,
kann ich auch empfehlen, über die Geschichte
von NPM selber
gehalten. Der hieß
The Economics of Open Source.
Okay.
Und ich spoil das jetzt, ihr könnt euch mal
fünf Sekunden die Ohren zu halten. Der endet
damit, dass sie ihre eigene Package Registry
vorstellen.
Es ging darum,
er hat erst gefragt, warum ist Ryan Dahl nicht reich?
der Typ, der Node.js
ach der, der, okay
und zwar so, der hat
Node.js losgetreten und der Typ
den hat sie nie erwähnt, der NPM
losgetreten hat, Isaac Schlüter, oder? Kann sein
er hat halt NPM losgetreten und irgendwann
ist Node an Joint
verkauft worden und NPM
nicht und NPM, das Problem mit
NPM ist, du musst halt Infrastruktur betreiben und
kriegst kein Geld dafür, also haben sie eine Firma gegründet
und NPM hat eigentlich nur so von Venture
Kapital gelebt bislang und hat immer mal nochmal
Venture-Kapital gesichert und irgendwann
mussten sie...
Darum geht dieser
Vertrag.
Ja, also
es ist wirklich gut.
Eigentlich tue ich dem
gerade kein...
Ich meine, sauf viele Firmen
brauchen mittlerweile
die NPM-Infrastruktur.
Das NPM
lief jahrelang
auf gesponserten Hosts von
CouchDB,
weil es eine CouchDB-Anwendung ist.
Ach so. Und es war quasi Werbung
für CouchDB. Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Und irgendwann hat CouchDB gesagt,
also so viel ist uns die Werbung jetzt doch nicht wert.
Und dann haben sie halt
irgendwie eine Firma gegründet und Venture Capital
angenommen. Kennen wir nicht einen, der bei CouchDB arbeitet?
Das ist nicht Clemens, der ist
ja nicht dort tätig. Oder so ein anderes
SternchenDB?
Das gebe ich mir ein gefährliches Halbwissen.
MongoDB?
Nee, das war es nicht.
Es kann sein, dass es CouchDB ist.
Egal. Aber ich weiß nur ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht
wirklich von mir. Ich weiß nicht, ob er was hört. Falls ja, dann
melde ich mal. Also die Frau war CTO
bei NPM.
Ja, zumindest zum Schluss hat sie dann gesagt,
Vorsicht, Spoiler,
wir bauen jetzt eine,
nicht einen neuen Paketmanager, aber eine
Distributed Package Registry.
Okay, eine für die wir nicht mehr so viel
eigene Infrastruktur bereitstellen müssen.
Ja, und dann, ich weiß nicht, wie sie es sich dann vorstellen,
dann werden sie,
da muss halt jeder so ein bisschen Infrastruktur.
Das klappt für Großabnehmer,
sage ich jetzt mal.
Ich schätze mal, Microsoft und Google werden
ihre eigene Host und damit hast du schon fast wirken.
Wenn das Ding wirklich
das Ding wird. Microsoft baut das in GitHub,
mit der Package Registry schon mit ein und dann nutzen
alle einfach GitHub. GitHub hat jetzt auch eine Package
Registry. Also Microsoft fundet jetzt quasi
die Developer von vorne bis hinten
alles. Genau, es war einer der Witze, den sie gemacht hat.
Du hast jetzt diese Open-Source-Bude
und du musst irgendwie
Geld verdienen und was machst du?
We can't all be saved by Microsoft.
Ja, das ist es wirklich.
Achso, genau, ich habe mit den Microsoft-Leuten so ein bisschen über GitHub geredet.
Sagt mal, ihr baut jetzt gerade hier einen Browser auf Chromium-Basis und ihr seid quasi die Inhaber von Electron, weil Electron so ein GitHub-Ding ist.
Und die beiden großen GitHub-Projekte, Editoren sind jetzt auch in eurer Firma mit VS Code und Atom.
greift er da, also macht er jetzt
schon sehr monopologisch.
Macht er jetzt bei
und den Satz hat ich glaube ich gar nicht so richtig zu Ende
gesprochen, also bloß so ein bisschen in Pleite,
hat der Typ schon gesagt, nein,
wir haben GitHub gekauft, weil GitHub uns wichtig
ist und wir geben denen einfach Geld und lassen
sie cool sein und
aber das ist derselbe Typ, der
Webpack maintainer, also ich weiß nicht wie tief der in die
wirtschaftlichen Interessen von Microsoft
reingucken kann, der ist auch bloß Entwickler dort.
Das ist auch ein Gigant als Firma
mit sehr unterschiedlichen Interessen an allen Ecken.
Man sieht ja schon,
auf der einen Seite machen sie coolen Open-Source,
auf der anderen Seite
hauen sie haufenweise Tracking-Scheiße in Windows
schon seit längerem rein.
Immer schlimmer, immer schlimmer.
Generell kannst du
einer Firma-Identität nicht trauen.
Sowieso nicht.
Per Definition schon nicht.
Es wird sich halt zeigen, was da noch passiert.
Aber schauen wir mal, wie es weitergeht.
Wie geht es denn weiter?
Es gab noch andere Vorträge.
Also wie gesagt, es gibt jetzt mindestens zwei neue Paketmanager und eine neue Registry.
Ashley Williams ist jetzt bei...
Das war AG Dubs, oder?
AG Dubs ist jetzt bei Cloudflare.
Ach, okay.
Sie und Steve Klepnik sind beide bei Cloudflare natürlich.
Ach, die Teamzusammenfund.
Die waren da beide und hingen da so ein bisschen beim Cloudflare-Stand rum und haben so ein bisschen darüber erzählt.
Das war eigentlich ganz putzig. Also die hat irgendwie über
Edge Computing einen Vortrag gehalten. Weißt du, was
Edge Computing ist? Ja, quasi
auf Cloudflare-Infrastruktur direkt
am Backbone des Internetseins.
Wir haben da festgestellt, ja, gerade nicht am Backbone,
sondern halt überall an den CDNs.
Achso, das ist ja nicht das, was Backbone betreut.
Wir haben da diese Rechenzentren festgestellt, dass die noch so ein bisschen
Rechenkapazität haben.
Am Kunden quasi. Direkt vor Ort.
Im Lokalwetter.
Nee, das gab es irgendwie nicht so.
Erzähl weiter.
Und die haben irgendwie vorgestellt, wie sie es gemacht haben.
Die lassen da überall V8 drauflaufen.
Und bei V8 kannst du halt ganz viele kleine VMs starten,
indem du einfach in der einen VM so ein, wie heißt das?
So ein Lightweight-Dinger.
Das war kein Container, sondern ein Isolat.
Das ist wirklich, wenn du mal in den V8 C++-Code reingeguckt hast,
dann ist halt so ein Stück Scope
einfach ein Isolid.
Dann kriegst du quasi echt nur so ein Stück Scope,
auf dem du ein bisschen Lambda ausführen kannst.
Und das wird halt irgendwann mal gescheduled,
wenn das...
Isolat klingt nicht viel besser als ähnlich klingende Wörter,
die ich nicht mag.
Ich habe da übrigens schon mal Kompromat gesammelt für dich.
Also da gibt es so ein Isolat,
den dein Code läuft.
Und naja, haben sie natürlich über Web-Islam-Leggeräte,
dass man das dann nutzen kann,
weil es schneller ist als ja es gibt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du auf der Ebene
einen großen Unterschied machst, wenn du so ein bisschen
Netzwerk zeigst. Aber krass, dass das auf irgendwie so
eine winzig
Lightweight VM-Sachen in V8
direkt passiert. Dinge, die
HLI
heute lernte ich.
Heute lernt.
Der Typ, der
dieses Sandspiel gemacht hat, hat den Vortrag
über das Sandspiel gehalten. Cool.
Der war natürlich auch darüber, übrigens
ich hab's einfach in WebAssembly mit Rust geschrieben.
Nein, so wie man's halt macht.
Wie man's halt macht.
Es gab Vorträge von
zwei TensorFlow-Leuten
über TensorFlow.js.
Aha. Brauchen wir sowas?
Ich dachte, es läuft jetzt alles auf Swift.
Ja, aber warum in Swift schreiben,
wenn du es auch in JavaScript schreiben kannst?
Genau.
Was war noch gut?
Was so ein bisschen
kontrovers war,
oder vielleicht einfach
von ein paar Leuten nicht so verstanden wurde,
Es gab einen Special Space,
das war der
BIPOC
Space
für Black,
Indigenous and People of Color.
Das war einfach so ein abgetrennter Raum
auf der JS-Conf, wo du nur hin durftest,
wenn du mehr Hautfarbe
als wir beide hattest.
Und das haben halt ein paar Leute,
es wurde ein bisschen diskutiert auf Twitter,
ein paar haben gesagt, aber warte mal,
wir haben doch gerade so viel gemacht, dass die Schwarten nicht
in ihren eigenen Raum müssen.
Oder sowas. Das ist
irgendwie komisch. Das hat einer geschrieben
auf Twitter. Das Letzte,
was die Leute wollen, ist irgendwie,
dass sie irgendwie in den eigenen
Raum sollen oder sowas. Aber es ist
halt zwar eher so als Safe Space gedacht,
dass die dort hingehen können.
Es ist auch keine Colored und White-Trennung hier.
Naja, du durftest da als Weißer nicht rein.
Ja, aber ich meine, das ist ja kein Müssen,
sondern eher ein Können. Ein Können, ne? Das ist ein Können.
So, das war also quasi, so wie
viele Konferenzen, so ein Safe Space
oder so einen Ruheraum aufgenommen haben,
wo du hingehen kannst,
wo du einfach dem Stress entgehen kannst,
hatten die, ich weiß nicht, ob die andere Konferenzen schon gemacht haben,
einfach so einen Raum für
quasi diverse Minorities
in dem Fall genommen.
Da gab es dann extra Vorträge darüber
für Minorities
in der Tech-Investition.
Haben sie die Idee, die man auch gefunden hat?
Ja.
Das finde ich auch wieder ein bisschen weird.
Also ich könnte nicht sagen, worum es da ging.
Ich habe aber auch leider wenig Leute getroffen,
die tatsächlich da reingepasst haben
oder mich mit wenig Leuten unterhalten.
Ich meine, generell so ein Safe-Paste zu haben,
auch wenn der dann halt für gewisse Personengruppen ist,
finde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt verkehrt.
Aber darin Vorträge abzuhalten,
finde ich irgendwie ein bisschen gemein.
Also, ich meine, du kannst ja gerne die Vorträge
auch nach draußen streamen.
Okay, aber das weiß ich nicht.
Also wie gesagt, dieses Thema wurde diskutiert,
weil es von einigen auch nicht so ganz verstanden wurde.
Und die, die es nicht verstanden haben,
die wurden dann manchmal auch direkt so als
ignorant dargestellt.
Es war alles ein bisschen
gefährlich und ich traue mich auch auf Twitter
bei solchen Diskussionen nicht wirklich daran teilzunehmen.
Das ist auch so eine Sache. Die meisten trauen sich gar nicht,
was zu sagen.
Du musst ja nichts dagegen sagen.
Also ich hätte
vielleicht möchtestens gefragt, es ist cool, dass ihr das macht.
Worüber habt ihr da geredet?
Ich hätte mich da schon für interessiert, aber auf der anderen Seite
ist dann, wenn
da alle
generischen weißen Europäer reingedurft hätten,
dann wären da wieder mehr generische weiße Europäer
drin gewesen, als die, für der Raum eigentlich
da gewesen wäre, keine Ahnung.
Sind wir generisch?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich es sprachlich safe
ausdrücken darf.
Also wie gesagt, ich hätte da nicht reingekonnt.
Die Musik war dieses Mal nicht von
meinem
Kollegen Khalil, der das irgendwie die letzten
zwei Jahre mit seiner Hip-Hop-Crew gemacht hat,
die haben irgendwie Musik mit JavaScript gemacht,
sondern diesmal war irgendwie so eine Techno-Gruppe,
Musik mit JavaScript gemacht hat. Die ging dann
echt davon los, die hatten diese riesen
Durchweg-Leinwand, wie auf der
DubDub.
Mit fünf Projektoren
so ein durchgängiges Screen.
Da lief die ganze Zeit auch Animation drauf.
Und manchmal haben sich halt Leute in den Gag gemacht und sind da hingegangen
auf diesen Rechner auf die Industrie, haben
rechts geklickt und haben irgendwie auf Inspect
geklickt und dann haben sie irgendwie im Zuberger
gezeigt. Da haben sie so, ja mach mal Rendering
an und dann siehst du irgendwie,
welche Stellen von dieser Animation neu gerendert
worden oder so. Das ist ja geil, du hast ja den
Debugger, weißt du, visualisieren. Das war ziemlich cool,
also das war alles mit Web-Technik gemacht,
das war eigentlich ziemlich nice. Nicht schlecht,
die JavaScript-Leute haben halt schon Spaß,
das ist ja so eine Sache.
Ne, wenn du gerade die DabDab ansprichst, die war ja auch noch
seit der letzten Folge. Das war auch direkt
eigentlich nach der nächsten Folge, da war die
DabDab, dann war JSConf,
dann war ich seltener bei BRN und dann war
wieder irgendwie drei Wochen rum, vier Wochen.
Ne, da hat Apple auch coolen Kram vorgestellt,
ich meine neben ein bisschen Hardware, ich ziehe
der Mac Pro, der
lang erwartete. Das fand ich krass,
da haben wir ein paar Mal so auf Arbeit überlegt.
Niemand braucht so ein Teil, es sei denn, du arbeitest
irgendwie in der Branche, wo du
wirklich Unmengen an
Video- oder Audio- oder Bilddaten verarbeitest.
Aber als Entwickler kommst du nicht
dran, dass du irgendwie so ein Ding brauchst. Ich meine,
der Low-Level-Mac, nicht jeder Mac Pro hat
1,5 Terabyte RAM. Ich würde gerne mal
sehen, welchen Anwendungsfeld tatsächlich diese
High-End-Teile sind, wenn das jetzt
was anderes als Filmstuhl. Ich schätze mal die Leute, die
auch, was weiß ich,
sowas wie Pixar würde sich da ein paar von
stellen, ne? Genau, das sind auch wirklich die Leute,
die Macs benutzen in der Branche.
Und ich schätze mal, jemand, der sich so ein Ding kauft,
wird auch argumentieren, das hält dann auch
für die nächsten 5-6 Jahre. Weil es halt auch
modular upgradable ist. Das ist halt ein PC.
Ja, du kannst Dinge rausnehmen, was halt bei Apple
in den letzten Jahren nicht mehr so typisch war bei den Geräten.
Ich habe heute ein Blogpost gesehen,
wie, das war auch auf
Hacker News, wie diese Front,
diese Käsereibe von dem Ding gestaltet
wird. Da haben sie irgendwie
visualisiert, wie diese einzelnen
wir haben Kugeln ineinander gelegt und angeordnet werden,
um dieses Käse-Refüll-Muster
zu erzeugen.
Der alte Mac Pro hat ja schon mal, also nicht die Mülleimer.
Aber für die Leute, die es nicht gesehen haben, was haben sie denn genau vorgestellt?
Sie haben einen neuen Mac Pro vorgestellt, also diesen
neuen Standrechner. Genau, das Display dazu.
Das Display dazu.
Du musst natürlich nicht das Display benutzen und du musst
ja auch nicht den Mac Pro haben für das Display,
aber das Display ist halt schon so ein Ding für sich.
Das Display ist irgendwie dicker
als unsere beiden MacBooks zusammen.
Das ist aber auch ein Display, das in einer ganz anderen
Liga spielt. Also so ein Display brauchst du, wenn
du absolute Farbtreue brauchst
und wenn du halt
und dazu noch die passende Helligkeit, also es gibt
kein... Der Kontrast ist irgendwie, die haben es
wirklich gemacht, dass sie unterhalb, was man immer bei einem LED
Display denkt, was aber nicht so ist,
dass du die... Kein Display ist farbtreu.
Dass du wirklich die LEDs hinter den
hellen Stellen heller machst, als hinter den
dunklen Stellen. Das machen, glaube ich, die LED
Displays nicht wirklich. Ich kenne mich da jetzt nicht im Detail
aus, wie die... Die meisten machen es einfach bloß
gleichmäßig hell und machen dann oben drüber
diesen Filter, schätze ich. Genau, aber das sind
ja wirklich Profiteile hier für Leute, die
wirklich in dem Sektor arbeiten, wo du das brauchst.
Also wirklich, also selbst die Leute,
die sich den Neumarkt Pro kaufen, ich behaupte,
die meisten von denen brauchen nicht dieses Display dazu.
Das Display sieht doch ganz schön martialisch aus.
Das ist schon krass. Hat hinten auch diese
selbe Struktur wie noch dieser
neue Schießgater? Genau. Das Display kostet
selber 3.000? 3.000,
schön wäre es. 4.000, 5.000.
5 oder 6, wenn du es matt haben willst. Ich würde gerne mal das
Matte in echt sehen, weil die haben irgendwie auch das
das Glas jetzt neu gemacht, sodass du ein mattes
Display ohne diese Noise-Artefakte hast.
Das war immer so das eine, was mich stört an dem
Display, dass du immer diese Noise-Artefakte hast.
Hast du mal hier an den Apple Store geguckt, ob hier so ein Ding rumsteht?
Noch nicht, die ist noch nicht raus. Aber die meinten
im Apple Store, dass sie die auch da vielleicht eins kriegen.
Aber ich bezweifle es ja, was in Dresden
so ein Ding steht. Und wenn, dann würde ich gerne das Matte
sehen und das bezweifle ich sehr.
Was ein bisschen lächerlich an dem Display ist, ist halt
der Stand extra kostet.
Und zwar nicht nur extra, so ein bisschen, sondern extra
1000 Dollar extra. Also es ist wirklich nur,
das haben sie oft gezählt, Rechner
5000 oder 6000.
Display 4000,
499.
Und der Fuß für das Display
999.
Da gab es dann auch irgendwie Sequenzen, die so auf YouTube
angucken konnten, wo so ein Raunen durch
das... Das war auch so super schnell.
Die Zeit gesagt, der Typ verschwand von der Bühne, Tim kam rein, hat
ins eine Weitere klaut. Haben die da gerade
echt gesagt, dass der Ständer 1000 Dollar kostet?
Ich meine, ist ein schöner Ständer,
gar keine Frage. Und die hätten...
Niemand würde sich darüber aufregen, wenn der Ständer bei dem Display
einfach dabei wäre und das ganze Ding einfach insgesamt
als Paket 1000 Dollar mehr kostet. Aber das Ding
einzeln zu verkaufen für 1000 Dollar.
Das hätte ich auch nicht laut gesagt.
Das ist absurd.
Die haben den Mac Pro Preis nicht erwähnt.
Ich glaube, den Einstiegspreis haben sie erwähnt, aber die haben nichts dazu
gesagt. Also keine Ahnung. Wenn du das Ding aufrüst,
das wird es bestimmt irgendwo im 50.000 Bereich.
Locker. Aber dann
den Preis für den Ständer.
Was kommt, wenn du das Display einfach so
kaufst? Ist da ein
schlechter Ständer dabei oder einfach gar nichts?
Kannst du das Ding einfach anlehnen an ein paar Bücher?
Die Aufhängung ist die gleiche
wie bei anderen. Das ist so ein Wesermount,
aber der kostet irgendwie, der Adapter dafür, oder das Ding
kostet auch 200 Dollar, also normal
in so einem Preissegment, würde ich sagen.
Was kostet 200 Euro?
Die Warthalterung für das Ding.
Aber wenn ich jetzt schon so einen Arm
habe, weil ich schon so ein Display da drauf hänge, kann ich
das neue Display da auch auf diesen Arm drauf?
Nee, das geht auch bei, die meisten Geräte brauchen
extra so einen Weser-Adapter, dass du da rankommst.
Achso, der kostet auch nochmal
200. Entweder war es
die ganze Halterung oder der Adapter.
exzessiv. Ich möchte behaupten, dass mit diesem
Fuß oder sowas, da haben sie ja auch wahrscheinlich eine ganze
Menge Engineering reingesteckt, damit
sie sich super leicht belegt. Es ist ein geiles Teil.
Es soll sich angeblich wunderschön anfühlen.
Weißt du, warum ich glaube, dass sie das gemacht haben?
Als Apple
vor ein,
zwei Jahren, vor zwei Jahren, diese neuen
MacBooks rausgebracht hat mit dieser Touchbar.
Das ist schon wieder mehr als zwei Jahre her.
Irgend so was, ja. Vier, fünf Jahre vielleicht?
Was? Nee, nee, nee.
Zwei oder drei Jahre vielleicht.
Ich weiß, dass ich vor zweieinhalb
Jahren bei der Firma angefangen habe und dann haben sie
mir gesagt, kauft ihr mal einen, sucht mal
einen Rechner aus, kann auch ein Mac sein
und ich so, ja, aber ich will nicht diesen
neuen Rechner, dieses neue MacBook, was da rausgekommen
ist, weil die Tastatur da scheiße ist. Anyway,
als das Ding rauskam,
kam gleichzeitig von Microsoft
dieses Surface Pro raus.
Surface Pro hast du vor Augen.
Das ist einfach bloß auch dieses Riesendisplay
mit dieser
zweifüchigen Halterung, wurde
super smooth irgendwie
in diesen Tablet-Modus, wo es so
auf 45 Grad Winkel wechseln kannst.
Und da gab es, dann hattest du noch
diesen Drehknopf dazu, den Drehknopf konntest du
da drauf tun und es war alles irgendwie, alle fanden es geil.
Jetzt hörst du davon auch nicht mehr, aber
in dem Moment kamen irgendwie mehrere
Blogposts raus, guck mal,
Microsoft baut jetzt
diesen super geilen PC,
ja, also mit diesem geilen
Bildschirm und was gibt es von
Apple an der Stelle? Na hier, es gibt
diesen, diesen, diese
Arschenbecher-Geschichte und
sie haben jetzt so ein bisschen Touch Bar in ihre Laptops
eingebaut. Das war's.
Apple ist jetzt nicht mehr cool.
Microsoft baut jetzt die geilen Dinger.
Von Apple gibt's ja auch diesen Cheese Grater,
gibt's ja auch gar nicht mehr.
Das schätze ich mal, das haben die sich gedacht,
nee, da müssen wir jetzt...
Da ist das falsche OS drauf, kannst du ja nicht nutzen,
sowas mit Windows.
Ja, ich weiß aber.
Nee, aber stimmt schon.
Windows hat jetzt das...
Da gibt's jetzt dieses Linux-Subsystem für Windows,
das wird jetzt noch besser...
Andersrum, Windows-Subsystem von Linux,
weiß ich nicht verstanden, warum das so heißt.
Das stimmt, das ist eigentlich fast schon.
Es ist ein Windows-Subsystem,
dafür, dass du da nichts machst.
Anyway, das wird jetzt irgendwie ausgebaut.
Achso, du meinst erweitert.
Erweitert.
Vielleicht ist es jetzt auch schon standardmäßig
dabei oder sowas.
Irgendwie wird das jetzt super fancy, ja.
Ja, und sie haben jetzt
Windows-Terminal.
Das sieht echt geil aus, das Ding. Muss ich dir lassen.
Endlich mal
ein geiles Terminal für Windows.
Schickes Ding mit Funktionalität, die man in dem Terminal
Erwarto erwartet. Das ist cool.
Also haben sie das natürlich ein bisschen aufgeholt.
Ne, warte mal kurz zurück zu WWDC.
Neben dem
einen großen Hardware-Downloads, wo manche Leute lange
drauf gewartet haben mit dem Mac-Broker, hast du natürlich viele große
Software-Updates, alle neue
Betriebssystem-Versionen mit ein paar neuen
Features, blabber, Krams.
Dein Code ist jetzt im
Xcode drin?
Nicht Teil von Xcode.
Teil von X-Bilds
oder X-Coden.
Es ist Teil vom
vom Swift Package Manager, wenn du
Swift startest,
also wenn du Swift Package, das sind
einzelne Tools, alles. Ja, aber ich meine
fast, das ist sogar drauf, wenn du die Xcode-Tools
noch nicht mal installiert hast. Das meinte,
habe ich mal letztens irgendwo ausprobiert, aber
egal, irgendwo ist mit drin.
Aber FindXCore ist immer noch nicht der Standard, leider.
Aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, war
ein großes, cooles Feature, was sie angekündigt haben,
ist jetzt nicht so Teil
der Betriebssysteme, also nichts
für iOS, WatchOS, macOS, Krams,
sondern dieses Swift UI
Framework, was ein
deklaratives UI Framework ist für Swift.
Und da gab es ja tatsächlich
etliche Gerüchte über die letzten
Jahre, dass sowas kommen sollte.
Und ich persönlich habe es einfach nicht
geglaubt, dass
dem wirklich so ist.
Aber jetzt ist es plötzlich da und es
sieht echt unglaublich fancy aus.
Und ich kann plattformübergreifend damit auf
wunderschöne Art und Weise
echt sauber UI-Code schreiben.
Und es ist
beeindruckend toll. Ich höre Vogel getwitschern plötzlich.
Ja, hier fliegen abends immer
extrem viele Swifts.
Das sind tatsächlich, wie heißen die, Turmsegler?
So ähnlich, oder?
Irgendwas Segler.
Ja.
Punkt.org.
Swift.
Nicht Schwalbe, das war
was anderes.
Mauersegler.
Das sind tatsächlich Mauersegler. Also es sind wirklich Swifts,
die hier um mein Hausdruck fliegen.
Es kreischt halt ein bisschen laut mit da.
Da habe ich aber auch Kritik zu gelesen.
Also das Ding sieht gut aus.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe es mir nicht genau angeguckt.
Ich hätte dich jetzt gefragt, ob man es irgendwie mit React oder sowas vergleichen kann.
Aber da kannst du mir das wieder nicht beantworten, weil du kein React kennst.
Also es geht in eine ähnliche Richtung von dem, was ich von React weiß, ja.
Aber es geht auf jeden Fall in eine ähnliche Richtung.
Aber es ist in C++ geschrieben.
Was? Wie? Hä?
Irgendjemand hat auf Twitter geschrieben,
das ist in C++ geschrieben.
SwiftUI.
Der Compiler ist in C++ geschrieben.
Nein, SwiftUI ist in C++ geschrieben.
Also das ist ziemlich Low-Level-Kram, was irgendwo
direkt Metal anspricht, was krass ist.
Das ist nicht einfach UI-Kit oder App-Kit-Code,
der übersetzt ist.
Das ist interessant, aber
finde ich ja witzig, dass das in C++ implementiert ist.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Ist zumindest so eine
so eine Aussage von irgendwem irgendwo.
Ich meine, das sollte sich doch relativ einfach rausfinden lassen,
wenn du die Frameworks dekompilierst, oder?
Das kannst du mal machen, wenn du das kannst.
Ich trau dir da mit der Aussage.
Ja, zumindest, ich finde es cool,
auch was sie vorgestellt haben, ist ja ganz nice.
Ich meine, ich habe leider überhaupt keine wirkliche Ahnung,
aber dass du jetzt mal eben,
da haben sie ja so ein paar Leute auf die Bühne geholt,
die einfach ihre iOS-Apps dann für den Desktop portiert haben.
Das ist ja nochmal die andere Geschichte,
dieses Project Cattles, was vorher im Hause bleiben ist.
Ach so stimmt, das wäre ja noch was anderes.
Aber das kommt dann auch dazu, weil du kannst halt jetzt
Zwift UI für beide Targets...
Nicht nur für die beiden, sondern für alle Targets quasi
den selben UI-Code schreiben.
Ob du jetzt das Ding auf WatchOS in der App schreibst
oder auf iOS oder auf MacOS oder auf TVOS.
Oder auf iPadOS.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie sehr iPadOS
wirklich ein eigenes OS ist oder bloß ein anderer Name
für den iOS-Bild für iPad.
In Zukunft wird es bestimmt weiter divergieren.
Aber...
in die Liste gesetzt. Das ist übrigens beides iOS.
Ein abgespecktes
iOS, was auf dem HomePod läuft.
Und auf den AirPods
ist es tatsächlich ein Real-Time-Betriebssystem.
Soweit ich weiß. Was aber witzig ist,
weil das denselben Prozessor wie ein iPhone 4 hatte.
Und da heißt, du hast quasi zwei iPhones in den Ohren stecken.
Und damit wiederholen wir uns von der
letzten Folge. Das hast du nämlich genau dort schon erzählt.
Ja, okay.
Ich suche gerade irgendwie
einen Tweet raus, den ich irgendwie kommentiert
hatte. Finde ich gerade natürlich nicht.
Twitter hat eine neue Oberfläche.
Was? Ich hatte schon eine Weile
diese Beta-Twitter-Oberfläche, die
einfach die mobile Oberfläche war, aber jetzt
ist das Menü links.
Ich kenne keine andere Oberfläche von Twitter.
Sieht Twitter bei dir nicht
so aus?
Ne.
The fuck is das?
Ich irgendwie wahrscheinlich in diesem Beta-Modus bin.
Oder sowas.
Zumindest
Warte mal, was ist denn jetzt hier bei mir?
Ich bin auf mein Profil gegangen.
Profil. Und dann gibt's hier
Tweet and Replies.
Genau.
Da hatte nämlich jemand
gepostet
einen Screenshot von, wie so eine
React-App gebootstrappt wird.
React schreibst du ja JSX.
JSX sieht aus wie HTML,
bloß dass du es aus irgendeinem Grund in
JavaScript reinschreibst. Und da
schreibst du halt Tags, die deine
Komponenten sind. Und da schreibst du manchmal so Provider-Tags
drumherum. Das heißt, du hast einen Tag, das ist einfach
ein XYZ-Provider. Und da
welche Contextdaten oder irgendwelche
Capabilities rein, wie entweder dein Store
oder irgendwas, was mit
deinem, mit deiner
Navigation Bar arbeitet oder
irgendwas, was auf, keine Ahnung,
Kontexte zugreifen kann.
Und die kannst du halt teilweise auch beliebig
tief ineinander schachteln. Da hat jemand diesen Screenshot
gepostet und das ist einfach bloß mal,
das sieht aus wie so ein Java-XML-Monster.
Das ist ein Navigation Store
Updater Provider,
beinhaltet einen Query Params Context
Provider, beinhaltet einen
Transition Context Provider beinhaltet,
einen Navigation State Provider beinhaltet,
einen Navigate Provider beinhaltet,
einen Go-Back Provider
beinhaltet die Root-Komponente
deiner eigentlichen App ist.
Ich habe unten drunter gepostet, hier
Seven Layers of Protective Boiler Plate
mit Clint Eastwood, wo er sich den Boiler Plate
irgendwie unter der Decke versteckt hat bei so einer Schießerei.
Schön, wunderschön.
Also es gibt jetzt,
ich hoffe, dass Swift UI
nicht so aussieht.
Also es kann so aussehen, aber du kannst
das ein bisschen sauberer strukturieren und
man kann
Code immer scheiße schreiben.
Dass das sehr hässlich wird,
Pyramid of Doom-Style, kannst du machen, wie du möchtest
und hast
idealerweise strukturiert oder sauberer,
ziehst die Komponenten auseinander in das,
was sie eigentlich sind und dann gibt sich das.
Aber das finde ich, wie gesagt, eine der coolsten
Features, die sie jetzt angekündigt haben.
Natürlich neben der Swift-Package-Manager-Integration
für Xcode und ich habe jetzt mal
in ein paar Apps, die ich noch so maintaine,
einfach mal komplett Cocoa Ports und Carthage,
das ist so die typischen
Package Manager in der iOS-Version gewesen,
und noch an Teilstellen, so zwei
GitHub-Modules, einfach alles rausgeworfen,
Zwift-Package ist reingezogen und es läuft. Es ist wunderbar.
Ich musste teilweise meine Dependencies forken
und noch ein Package Manifest
dazulegen, aber
ich meine, da kann ich gleich ein paar PRs aufmachen.
Und wo liegen die Pakete dann
beim Zwift-Package Manager?
Die liegen in einem Punkt-Swift-PM-Directory da mit drin.
Da checkt ihr die aus.
Ja, gut, okay, das ist ja dein Node-Modul-Version.
aber wo hält die her?
Achso, es gibt keine Registry.
Also aktuell noch nicht.
Die sind da als URLs
direkt zum Git-Repo.
Aber das sind aktuell GitHub-Links bei allen von den Packages,
die ich brauche.
Wie machst du da Versionierung? Kannst du einen Tag angeben?
Genau, Visual Package macht Versionierung
über Git-Tags.
Besser als nichts.
Besser als ich schreibe GitHub-URLs
direkt an den Kopf meiner...
Es sind Semper in Git-Tags, die im Manifest
liegen. Das finde ich tatsächlich eine echt schicke
Lösung. Es ist halt festgelegt auf
Git. Theoretisch sollte auch mal, also du kannst
natürlich auch einfach eine Directory angeben, das geht auch.
Kannst du auch Pijool?
Du kannst natürlich nicht Pijool nutzen,
weil keine Saunus Pijool.
Noch nicht, ich sage dir, noch nicht.
Prinzipiell wäre es natürlich schick, das offen zu haben.
In fünf Jahren werden wir sagen, weißt du noch, damals alle noch
Git genommen haben. Wenn du CVS-Support
im SWPM haben möchtest, geht bestimmt
irgendwie reinzuhacken.
Das war nicht alles schlecht im
CVS. Nee, keine Ahnung, ich habe die CVS-Support.
Ich habe CVS genau einmal benutzt.
tatsächlich für ein Projekt, wo es jemand
genutzt hat noch. Das war unerwartet.
Wo ist denn der Code hier? Er liegt in dem
Repo da. Ah, cool. Wie klone ich das denn?
Das ist CVS.
Was heißt das?
Weißt du?
Das war unerwartet.
Das geht mir aber tatsächlich auch.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, mach mal
SVN oder CVS, werde ich unsicher.
Richtig Schiss hatte ich bei
bei
Perforce.
Das habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Perforce hatten wir auf Arbeit auf irgendwelchen Stellen.
Das hat echt krasse UIs.
Und irgendwie lagen
sehr viel von unserem Brot in der Firma jahrelang
in Perforce. Und das hieß immer,
das performt besser bei großen Projekten.
Geht das auch erst 14 Jahre jung?
Und bei Perforce
konntest du absolut nicht merchen, aber du konntest irgendwie
andere Leute direkt immer die Sachen
zerschießen. Und du musst irgendwie, du hast
einen Account gehabt und dann hast du irgendwie
einen Stand, du hast quasi Online
Branches angelegt, auf denen du lokal gearbeitet hast.
Du musstest quasi für jeden deiner Computer
eine andere. Ich habe das Paratigma
nie verstanden. Ich hatte bloß
jederzeit Schiss, weil ich nicht verstanden habe, was ich da mache,
dass ich anderen Leuten ihren Code zerschieße.
Und ich weiß, dass wir teilweise Wochen
gebraucht haben, um irgendwelche Feature-Branches zu merchen.
Weil die Branches
quasi auch bloß Unterordner
also wie gesagt, ich habe es nicht verstanden. Vielleicht haben sie es auch alle
völlig falsch benutzt. Aber ich bin
froh, dass es weg ist. Und jetzt haben wir
irgendwie den Code, den wir in
mehreren
Perforce-Verzeichnissen hatten, alle
in einem großen Monorepository
in Git in der Firma.
Und das funktioniert.
Also Git kommt auch. Ich hab mal nachgeguckt.
Warte mal. Wir machen unser
zentrales Repository rein.
Unser Plattform-Repository.
Und das hat
Git-Count.
93.429
Commits.
Okay. Krass.
Da ist Code drin, der 15 Jahre
zurückreicht.
Weil wir natürlich alles mit History mitgenommen haben.
Das find ich immer cool.
Wenn ich mal drei Tage nichts auschecke, ziehe ich mir
ein paar hundert neue Commits runter.
Das hat mir auch bei Apple Spaß gemacht,
die History von Sachen reinzuschauen,
ganz an den Anfang.
Wenn man versucht, so Gorse zu werfen,
dieses Visualisierungstool auf,
das Xcode-Repo.
Das muss die Geschwindigkeit
erstmal passend einstellen, damit du
durch die Jahre überhaupt durchkommst.
Damit du das nicht wochenlang laufen lässt.
Das war witzig.
Was ist sonst noch vorgestellt worden?
Was ich eigentlich noch am spannendsten fand,
worüber nicht so viel geredet wurde,
war diese Sprachsteuerung für Leute mit Einschränkungen.
Das haben sie auch stark aufgebohrt.
Du hast jetzt schon immer
Full Keyboard Access in macOS,
dass du quasi durch jegliche UI
durchtappen kannst
und mit Enter und Space da durchnavigieren.
Das haben sie mächtig aufgebohrt.
Vorher war es Full Keyboard Access
mit Anführungsstrichen.
Jetzt ist es Full Keyboard Access
und du kannst wirklich alles machen.
Das ist beeindruckend.
Und das, was die da als Demo gemacht haben,
wie die Leute mit diversen Einschränkungen
ihre Systeme bedient haben, das war ja
faszinierend.
Hat der Typ gemacht, Videos geschnitten
oder sowas? Ich glaube, der hat auf einer Map noch
navigiert, aber auch so eine
tatsächlich sehr
fast so Sprachassistent-Style
navigiert, von wegen
hier zeig mir mal ein Grid an,
nehm Sektor 4F und zoom da viermal rein.
Okay, die Anweisung
ist verstanden worden,
da ist doch maximal Siri dahinter
das läuft.
Siri hat jetzt auch eine voll
virtuelle Stimme, eine voll generierte
Stimme und nicht mehr so. Ja, klingt viel besser,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob das das deutsche Siri
verlangt. Ich werde es wahrscheinlich nie merken, weil ich es nie benutze.
Ich nutze Siri tatsächlich mit dem HomePod.
Lass uns mal nicht so viel über Apple reden.
Ja, aber das kommt die ganze Zeit
gesprochen. Aber klar, wir müssen jetzt nicht hier
die ganzen Themen, die die Leute eklig finden können,
aber wir müssen zum Facebook-Thema weitergehen.
Oh Gott, das wird unser
Intro-Gag dieses Mal.
Ne, was ist denn bei Facebook?
Die haben Krypto-Coin.
Ah, stimmt, ja.
Das war ja jetzt schon eine Weile im Gespräch.
Das kam vor ein paar Monaten schon mal auf.
Echt, ja?
Aber jetzt ist wohl, haben sie es mit den Code dazu veröffentlicht,
Libra nennen die das Ganze.
Ich habe nicht viel an Meinung spezifisch dazu,
außer dazu, dass ich nicht Facebook als Macht hinter
wahrscheinlich einer populäreren Krypto-Coin sehen möchte.
Weil, ich meine, die wird populärer sein,
einfach nicht online, weil Facebook dahinter steht.
Hast du das dir mal auf GitHub angeguckt?
Ich habe das Webber gesehen.
ich hab drüber kurz gefreut und dann
Ekel empfunden, dass es Rust ist, aber
also gefreut, dass sie es nutzen, aber
dann Ekel war halt cool, aber warum
ich mein
cool wär's gewesen, wenn die das Ding in Hack
gewastelt haben, heißt doch Hack, oder?
Der hat mir gedacht,
das wär super cool gewesen
auf jeden Fall
ne, also ich hab einer von den
Rustations, der relativ viel
krasses Zeugs macht
oder mal mit dem Namen jetzt hier einfällt
Tomaka.
Tomaka, genau.
Der arbeitet an,
der hat auch ein, zwei Vorträge schon beim RESTfest gehalten.
Da habe ich auch schon mal kurz mit dem gequatscht.
Der arbeitet an LibP2P mit.
LibP2P ist
so eine Library für Peer-to-Peer-Anwendungen.
So, die haben irgendwie,
LibP2P is composed of many modules in different parts.
Here you can see an overview of all the different libraries
we develop along with the status of the implementation.
Die haben so
Transports, Stream Maxes,
Crypto Channels, Discovery, Peer Routing,
Record Stores,
Nut Traversal, Connection
und Connection Upgrade Stuff.
Und die haben halt ihre eigenen
WebSocket Implementierungen,
RTC Zeugs sogar drin, krass,
sehe ich gerade zum ersten Mal, die haben irgendwie UDP Zeugs,
ich meine alles drin, um
dein eigenes
BitTorrent oder dein eigenes
deine eigene CryptoCoin
Ja, so eine P2P-Anwendung.
Und der Typ hat dann auch hinterher
kommentiert zu Libra. Also nochmal, Libra ist
jetzt eine Kryptocoin oder
so angeblich eine Kryptocoin von
Ich weiß nicht, angeblich.
Keine Ahnung, wer weiß, was das wirklich hier unten drunter ist.
Ich habe es mir nicht genau angeguckt. Sie sagen, das ist eine Kryptocoin.
Aber du wirst es wahrscheinlich nicht merken,
dass es eine Kryptocoin ist. Das ist halt von der Währung.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass du selber
meinen werden wirst oder sowas.
Ich habe die Frage, wie sie das Proof-Work-Konzept
umsetzen.
Zumindest, der hatte das kommentiert mit, also ich hätte das nicht angenommen, aber es wäre witzig gewesen, wenn sie mir bei der ganzen Arbeit, wie sich das überschneidet zwischen Libra und Lipid-to-Peer, wenn sie mir einen Job angeboten hätten.
Hättest du dir vielleicht für eine Million gemacht oder sowas?
Ja, ich glaube für eine Million hätte ich mal kurz meine Seele verkauft.
Und der hat den Code mal geskimmt und dann gab es dann so Tweets wie
Repositories
where they use
also der hat gesagt,
Repositories, wo sie als Typ-Parameter
das Muster, Großbuchstabe und dann
ein klein Wort benutzen.
LibP2P und Libra.
Also der hat zumindest
so angedeutet, dass die den LibP2P
Code zumindest gelesen haben, um dann
Libra zu implementieren.
Deswegen hat er dann wahrscheinlich auch gemeint,
ach, dann hätten sie mir mal einen Job angeboten.
Naja.
sehr ähnlich dort arbeiten.
Komische Firma.
Ja, also ich
glaube, der Hauptgrund, warum sie es machen, ist,
dass in China
WeChat als Währung verwendet wird.
Oder dass die Leute über WeChat bezahlen.
Bezahlen, aber du bezahlst du nicht mit
einer eigenen WeChat-Währung, oder?
So wenig weiß ich über China,
dass ich jetzt behaupten möchte.
Du kannst ja, glaube ich, virtuelle WeChat-Credits
hin und her schieben, oder?
Das wusste ich bisher nicht. Ich dachte immer, es geht über
normale Währungen, die du einfach mit WeChat bezahlst.
sein, aber ich meine, WeChat ist
trotzdem irgendwie ein Social Network, was gleichzeitig
der Zahlungsprovider ist.
WeChat ist alles.
Und ich schätze mal, die Ambition hat Facebook
einfach, dass die irgendwie sagen,
okay, wir haben jetzt schon das dritte Social Network
nach Facebook, WhatsApp und Instagram
und wir können nicht einfach immer neue
Ableger von uns selbst rausbringen.
Wir müssen irgendwie die Machtergreifung anders machen,
als bringen wir jetzt eine Währung raus.
Ich meine, es ist eine große Firma
mit vielen Köpfen, die wollen
mit deren Endgame.
Klar, dass die sich natürlich da
möglichst divers aufstellen wollen,
aber
gefühlt war das alles immer schon so halb am Sterben
wieder. Wer nutzt denn noch Facebook heutzutage?
Also nutzen viele, aber
das ist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr
derselbe Anreiz wie vor ein paar Jahren.
Insta ist jetzt halt so das Ding.
Wo Insta, ehrlich gesagt, bis heute nicht wirklich verstanden.
Das ist auch überhaupt nicht.
Leider ist man halt gezwungen, ein bisschen WhatsApp
hier und da zu nutzen.
Aber das ist ja auch ein Messenger,
dementsprechend was anderes. Ich weiß
es nicht. Die haben halt ihre Plattformen und
natürlich haben die Unmengen an Geld.
Mit Insta machen sie vielleicht Werbegeld,
mit Facebook machen sie Werbegeld,
mit WhatsApp, weiß nicht, ob sie damit Geld machen oder
nicht wahrscheinlich. Du hast halt perfekt, es geht halt
prinzipiell um den
Zugriff auf, du willst wissen, wer
mit wem kommuniziert und den sozialen Grafen weiter
ausbauen und wissen, wem du da
zusammenstecken kannst in die passenden Werbetöpfe.
Das ist ja der große
Gag daran und prinzipiell ist es ja egal,
verschlüsselt ist oder nicht, weil die
Metadaten halt so oder so da sind. Du weißt, wer
mit wem wann kommuniziert, du weißt, wann Leute
schlafen, du weißt, wer im selbstsozialen
Graphen hängt, du kannst die Leute besser
verknüpfen, wenn du weißt, also wenn du
nur spärliche Profile hast, haust du die
Daten halt zusammen, weil du weißt, dass
der da ist und dann hast du auch die Telefonnummer
von dem und sonstige Sachen.
Also da gibt es schon
viele Möglichkeiten, wie das einen Mehrwert bieten kann.
Tja, vielleicht
Das ist es.
Shit, warum sind wir da nicht drauf gekommen?
Ich habe ja tatsächlich eine der ersten
größeren Anwendungen, die ich gebaut hatte,
war ein soziales Netzwerk.
Ich hatte irgendwie
als Schüler... Das Gästebuch, oder was?
Tatsächlich, ja, ja.
Ich hatte irgendwie
als Schüler, eigentlich habe ich tatsächlich PHP gemacht,
weil es gab halt so Lenslamp-Server.
Das waren die Zeiten, wo jeder
PHP gemacht hat. Genau. Und da habe ich
für meine Webseite ein Gästebuch gemacht und da habe ich
Freunde gefragt, wir haben auch eine Webseite, können wir uns
Gästebuch haben und dann habe ich irgendwann
rumgespielt habe, Feature Creep, und da habe ich dem Ding noch
eine Kommentarfunktion gegeben und plötzlich konnte man sich anmelden
und dann haben wir irgendwie in der 11. Klasse alle
über mein Gästebuch miteinander geschrieben.
Geil. Genau, und dann habe ich
irgendwie für die Schule irgendwie so eine Abi-Webseite
gemacht, wo man sein Profilbild hochladen konnte
und sowas. Krass. Das hieß dann irgendwie
Yearbook oder sowas. Das hieß tatsächlich Yearbook.
Da wusste ich noch nichts von Facebook.
Und dann habe ich
gesagt, ja, wir können alle ihre Abi, können sich
jetzt alle, die bei uns Abi machen an der Schule, dort anmelden.
irgendwie abi.schulname.de
und das hat nie jemand gemacht.
Mich haben dann auch Leute gefragt, was, ich stelle doch nicht meine Profilpartner
ins Internet. Ich so, das ist alles, du musst da irgendwie
einen Account haben und das ist nicht die ganze Zeit.
Nein, das mache ich nicht.
Und ein halbes Jahr später habe ich mich gefragt, was, warum machst du
nur dann deine eigene Seite? Es gibt doch Studi-Fullset.
Und ich habe gesagt, was ist denn Studi-Fullset?
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, oh fuck.
Die haben dich geshörlockt.
Naja, Studi-Fullset war ja einfach nur ein Ripp-off von Facebook.
Facebook-Book gab es da schon längst, bloß dass ich davon nicht wusste.
Echt? Waren die wirklich?
Als ich das Hierbuch gebaut habe,
gab es schon Facebook.
So jung bist du.
Ja.
Das waren so pre-Myspace-Zeiten.
Es war noch PHP.
Ach du weißt, die Versionsnummer von PHP?
3, 5.
Oh, großartig.
PHP 5 nicht.
6 war das nicht existent, was ich vorhin meinte.
Vielleicht gab es 5, 10 Jahre lang,
bevor es 7 gab? Keine Ahnung.
PHP ist lange her bei mir.
Ich weiß auch manchmal nicht mehr, ob es noch
BRP ist
oder nicht
Perl oder doch bloß mein Passwort.
Ich hoffe, der
Titel der letzten Folge hat nicht irgendwo was kaputt
gemacht, aber bisher
scheint es über zu laufen.
Er führt auch Podcast-Namen.
Mein
WLAN-Name ist
eine SQL-Injection. Ich dachte, der WLAN-Name war
eine Folkbomb.
Ach stimmt, nee, das WLAN
von meinem Handy-Hotspot ist das
Google-Hot-Spot.
Also damit könnte ich tatsächlich rumgehen und wenn irgendwo
irgendwer WLAN-Passwörter in eine
nicht gut escaped Datenbank tut.
Stimmt, wenn man einfach so quasi
ein Passiv-Angriff fährt, einfach nur, wenn du durch
die Gegend gehst, wenn jemand da Scheiße macht.
Das ist total passiv, wenn du dein Kind
Bobby Tables nennst.
Das ist mein Username bei der Deutschen Bahn.
Zwar, wenn ich mich einmal
kenne, du musst nicht wieder das Little Bobby Tables an.
Oh Gott.
Ich bin so doof, Mann, aber ich kann ihn nicht ändern.
Ach, du kannst ja nicht ändern.
Nee, kann man nicht ändern.
Das ist wenigstens irgendwie mit Anführungsstrichen oben.
Nee, das ist wirklich ein Literally Little Bobby.
Alles andere Besonderteilchen
wollten sie nicht zulassen.
Aber
wo wir gerade über die letzte Folge nochmal
geredet haben, was ja wirklich schön funktioniert,
muss ich sagen, ist unser Riot Chat.
Ja, das war erstaunlich.
Wir kriegen Feedback.
Dass das Leute sich da direkt eingeklinkt haben.
Vielen lieben Dank und schöne Gruße an dieser Stelle.
Hallo an alle.
dem Atrix-Channel.
Ich habe zum Beispiel vom Herrn Schmidtler auch direkt mehrere
Tab-
Grouping-Extension-Empfehlungen
für Firefox gekriegt.
Dieses Tab-Panorama, was in Firefox
mal eingebaut war, was da irgendwie mit der
Web-Extension-Umstellung rausgeflogen ist,
zu meinem Bedauern, gibt es als Web-Extension
wieder. Aber es soll nicht so richtig performen.
Aber man kann sich das, es hat irgendein Japaner
auf GitHub gestellt, vielleicht hat er
einfach bloß das alte portiert und
irgendwie Web-Extension-kompatibel gemacht, oder nicht?
Es gab ja nicht von Anfang an alle APIs,
dass das hätte möglich sein können, keine Ahnung.
Wollte ich nochmal,
das würde ich mir nicht gerne installieren, aber ich glaube,
das würde ich vorher nochmal wetten.
Obwohl, ich habe auf der
JS-Conf mit einem
Firefox-Mitarbeiter geredet.
Gab es direkt ein paar.
Wie gesagt, I like your work.
Und
habe den so nach Extensions
gefragt und die sind wirklich dran,
von den Extensions, die sie
auf addons.mozilla.org
freistellen, dass sie die alle
grob reviewen
und den Code sich angucken.
Krass. Was?
Das ist harte Arbeit und die
schauen da auch bloß scharf drauf.
Du kannst ja wahrscheinlich relativ viel
da automatisieren, was das Ding für Zugriffe hat.
Aber ich meine bei Firefox Extensions, ich weiß nicht
wie häufig du dir Chrome oder Safari Extensions installierst,
da kriegst du halt beim Installieren
schon immer gesagt, der muss auf
deiner Webseite Zugriffe haben,
der muss auf deine History Zugriffe haben, der muss auf deine Bookmarks
Zugriffe haben. Also du hast wie,
wenn du eine App installierst, siehst du eigentlich, was die für
Capabilities haben. Bisher ist es genauso
bei Safari-Extensions. Du installierst
mittlerweile eine App aus dem
Mac App Store, die die App-Extension
bundelt oder halt auch vielleicht nur die Extension ist.
Aber ist das dann auch eine Web-Extension?
Nein, das ist völlig was Eigenes.
Aber ich glaube,
ich habe drei oder vier Extensions
in Safari drin und das war es.
Das ist halt das Coole, weil du die halt theoretisch mit deiner App
bundeln kannst. Wenn du eine App hast, kann die App auch direkt
mitgebundelt haben in der Safari-Extension.
Der macht 1Password das so.
Das ist natürlich cool, wenn du das machen kannst.
Wenn du etwas anderes...
Ansonsten gibt es noch die klassischen
alten Safari-Extensions.
Da habe ich jetzt sowas wie uBlockOrigin noch installiert.
Und da zeigt Safari mittlerweile an,
so ein kleines Warnungssymbol.
This extension will slow down your Webbrowsing.
Weil der halt
so wie das Ding halt reinhakt,
der hat glaube ich ja einfach
Blocklisten auf Dinge,
die der nutzt, beziehungsweise
regex-basierte Sachen.
Und so läuft das ganze Ding.
Ansonsten habe ich, ich habe hier
noch eine weitere Extension installiert
und das ist so ein Ding, was Google Analytics
Tokens, also URLs rauschippt,
diese UTM-Dinger, damit ich die
nicht mehr sehen muss und aus Versehen,
wenn ich jemandem einen Link aus dem Newsletter
weiterleite. Hast du dir das aus Links direkt
rausgefiltert? Genau, das schippt er einfach aus der
URL-Bar raus. Das ist ja nicht schlecht. Also ich habe
hier so ein paar Sachen installiert tatsächlich.
Das können wir eigentlich mal, jetzt
wo wir drüber reden und wo wir Feedback von unseren Hörern
bekommen haben. Was nutzten ihr so
Was benutzt du hier so für Extensions? Ich habe hier
witzigerweise
Disable WebRTC installiert.
Gerade du.
Aber ich weiß auch, was mit WebRTC
Tracking möglich ist. Also wenn du das
hast, wenn du bei Safari
so ein Add-on hast oder findest, dann würde
ich dir das fast auch nahe legen.
Weil wenn du eine Peer-Connection aufmachst und
so dieses Ice-Gathering, was
dir erlaubt, eine Peer-to-Peer-Connection zwischen zwei
Browsern aufzumachen, ist wirklich in der Lage,
deine lokale IP rauszufinden. Das
im Netzwerk irgendwo erreichbar wärst.
Eine Peer-Connection macht teilweise sogar
irgendwie einen passiven Port bei dir auf dem Rechner auf,
um irgendwie Zugriff zu erlauben.
Halt für andere Peer-to-Peer-Anwendungen.
Aber wie willst du
sonst mit deinem
Webbrowser
einen Up- und Downstream
mit einem anderen
Dings aufmachen, mit einem anderen Webbrowser aufmachen?
Krass. So, das macht sowas.
Alles das, wo...
Ich weiß, dass ich mich mal irgendwo unterhalten habe,
als ich noch Tutor für
das SWT-Praktikum war, da haben sie
auch gesagt, ja, wir benutzen Skype für unsere
Unterhaltung und da haben sie zu den Mitarbeitern von der Firma,
wo wir waren, gesagt, mach doch auch,
lass uns ja über Skype mal miteinander reden und der so,
müssen wir nicht jedes Mal
hierher kommen, die waren so ein bisschen außerhalb
und da hat er gesagt, nee, Skype ist
bei uns verboten, das durchsticht Firewalls.
Das durchsticht Firewalls.
Und ab vor allem, dass klar war, was
Skype so macht oder so,
da haben sie mir gedacht, ja krass,
wie kommt eigentlich Skype durch die Firewalls durch?
Ich meine, du hast ja,
wenn du hinter einem NAD sitzt, hast du keine Public-IP.
Was die
im Endeffekt machen, ist die gleiche, diese ganz
konventionelle Kombination aus
Done und Turn, mit der du irgendwie eine
Verbindung zwischen zwei Rechner aufmachen kannst,
die jetzt in jeder
Web-ATC-Anwendung
implementiert ist und so weiter und so fort.
Und
die du
auch an der Uni lernst.
Also zwei Kollegen von mir halten morgen
in der Uni einen Vortrag in der Vorlesung
Internet in Web-Applications
über web.it.c. Das ist cool.
Aber nun ja, in meinem Firefox habe ich es deaktiviert
und ich habe einen Button jetzt in meiner
Toolbar oben, wo ich es dann
selektiv anmachen kann.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Ich habe irgendwie so ein Dr. Go-Such-Plugin.
Das muss ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, stelle ich gerade fest.
Dann habe ich irgendwie dieses
Firefox Multi-Account-Containers.
Das kann ich nur empfehlen. Das ist wirklich nice.
Das klingt echt sinnvoll.
Das macht einfach, dass du
einen neuen containerized-Tab aufmachen kannst.
Der hat dann so einen farbigen Balken
ich habe einen Container, der heißt Work
und ich habe einen, der heißt Einkaufen
und ich habe einen, der heißt GitHub und ich habe einen, der heißt
WhatsApp und einen, der Twitter heißt
und habe eingestellt, dass die Webseiten
dann in diesen respektiven Tabs aufgehen
oder Containern aufgehen und dann gelten
gewisse Einstellungen
und Cookies nur da drin.
Das gibt es nochmal gesondert als
Facebook-Container, das ist einfach genau dasselbe
Ding mit einem voreingestellten Facebook-Container.
Weil du ja
überall diese Facebook-Tracking
Geschichten drin hast, die dann einfach
in diesem Container in deinem Facebook eingeloggt
sein und wenn du irgendwie auf heise.de so einen
Like-Button drin hast, dann weißt der nicht, dass
du du bist. Heise ist ja eh cool, die
machen das ja gar nicht so. Bei denen ist das
irgendwie ausgegraut und es wird erst geladen, wenn du das
anmachst oder so. Diese Two-Stage-Buttons irgendwie
vergessen, die hat irgendeinen so komischen
Namen dafür, aber
ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob die Webseiten sich das noch
ans Bein binden, sowas zu machen, aber
es gibt genug Webseiten, die Facebook-Kommentare
eingebildet haben, aber das verkehrt natürlich auch, das wäre
Das ist ja eklig.
Dann irgendwie so Tracking Protection ist ja in Firefox schon standardmäßig drin mittlerweile,
aber es macht ja noch keine Werbung aus, also habe ich noch sowas wie U-Block Origin drin.
Du bist nicht so ein U-Matrix-Nutzer?
U-Matrix?
Das war so das krassere U-Block Origin.
Das, keine Ahnung, habe ich mir nicht angeguckt, kann sein.
Vielleicht ist das gut.
Was habe ich denn noch?
Ein paar Sachen, die aus diesen Experimenten von Firefox selber rausgefallen sind.
das Multi-Container-Dings war,
Multi-Tab-Container war auch,
Multi-Account-Container-Tab war so ein Experiment
von Firefox selber. Und da gibt es noch
Snooze-Tab.
Da sagst du, machen wir mal diesen Tab zu, aber machen
bitte nächsten Montag um 9 Uhr früh wieder auf.
Das ist ein witziges Feature.
Dann gibt es ein
Terms of Service didn't read.
Das blendet dir in der
URL-Leiste auf Webseiten die Terms of Service
ein und so ein Rating von A bis C
oder A bis F, wie gut das ist.
Wenn ich jetzt hier auf
GitHub gehe, habe ich da oben
in B stehen,
das klicke ich drauf und da steht
Class B, the terms and services are fair
towards the user, but they could be improved.
Und dann so eine Liste von
Sachen, die gut sind und die nicht gut sind.
This service ignores the
do not track header.
Das ist schlecht.
Your code can be suspended
and your data deleted at any time
for no reason, weil das irgendwann mal passiert ist.
Aber die guten Sachen sind,
was weiß ich,
so that changes can be viewed over time.
Und ganz viele Sachen.
Das war GitHub.
Und wenn ich auf Twitter gehe,
dann hat das,
die Seite muss leider zu Ende laden,
steht hier Fragezeichen.
Ist immer noch nicht geladen.
Bei Twitter bleibt es ein Fragezeichen.
Ach nee, jetzt ist es,
We haven't sufficiently reviewed the terms of service yet.
Da kannst du aber Hilfe...
Da gibt es hier einen Link zu einer Google Group, wo du das verbessern kannst.
YouTube kriegt ein D.
Class D, terms of service are very uneven and there are some important issues that need your attention.
Da kannst du jetzt hier in Ruhe...
Was ist denn jetzt so richtig negativ?
Deleted videos are not really deleted.
They can remove your content at any time without prior notice.
Und so weiter und so fort.
Also das Add-on ist wirklich ganz cool.
Klingt cool.
Aber es hat mich ehrlich gesagt auch noch nie wirklich davon abgehalten, eine Seite zu benutzen.
Ja, aber man will es zumindest auch ja am Blick haben.
Das finde ich besser als...
Ich meine, klar weiß man, dass Google- und Facebook-Produkte irgendwo ein bisschen...
naja sind.
Aber es ist schön, bei auch anderen Seiten mal so ein direktes Sternerating zu haben.
Das ist doch dieses alte Web of Trust-Dingens,
was in so einem farbigen Icon,
den man Git hat,
irgendwie,
wie vertrauenswürdig diese Seite ist.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so ähnlich.
Das ist das gleiche Konzept.
Und eine Sache, die ich noch habe,
ist hier OctoTree.
Das war so ein...
Das zeigt ja einfach auf GitHub
auf jeder Unterseite
den verzeichnenden Baum von dem Repo an.
Was auch ganz nice ist,
weil das bei GitHub selber nicht so gut ist.
dass man dieses Enhanced GitHub
Dings ausprobiert. Was macht das?
Das ist so ein Firefox-Addon, was
wirklich alles möglich ist.
Oh, vielleicht fast nur ein Chrome-Addon.
Die sind auch eigentlich kompatibel miteinander.
Du kannst die teilweise links und rechts,
also du kannst sie bei beiden teilweise installieren,
deswegen ist ja Firefox extra auf diese Web-Extension-API
gegangen. Die ist, glaube ich, auch irgendwo
W3C
gespeckt.
Ist gar nicht
Extension-API.
Gibt es da ein?
zumindest sehr exzessiv
auf MDN
dokumentiert.
Das ist ja richtig, wenn das ein cooler offener Standard ist.
Bestimmt, wenn der wirklich
überhaupt misst wird.
Es ist alles mehr oder weniger hinfällig,
weil es gibt nur noch Firefox und alle anderen
Chrome-Browser.
Das ist ein bisschen, aber ja.
Ich bin irgendwie ein bisschen negativ geworden, was so
Browser-Standards angeht in den letzten
Monaten. Dadurch, dass
also du konntest immer sagen,
Es gibt Chrome, den wir benutzen
fast alle. Es gibt Firefox,
das ist ein kompletter Browser. Und dann gibt's
Edge, die geben sich Mühe.
Und Safari? Und Safari,
das ist quasi der Stand von Chrome von
fünf Jahren oder sowas. Was?
Das ist doch WebKit.
Ja, aber
das ist ja nicht so, dass das nicht weiterentwickelt wurde.
Ja, und dann gibt's noch Safari, die machen
WebKit. Das ist das, was für Chrome nicht mehr gut
genug war.
Kommt das auch schon irgendwie eine sehr wertende Aussage?
Ja, also zumindest es gab,
Es gab mal vier Browser, jetzt gibt es nur noch
drei und zwei davon sehen sich extrem ähnlich.
Es gibt noch eine ganze Reihe mehr Browsers.
Was ist mit Opera passiert?
Opera ist ein Chrom. Ja, mittlerweile.
Ja. Ja. Also ich meine bloß,
sie fallen wie die Fliegen. Was ist mit Conqueror
passiert? Mit Midori?
Das waren alles Webkit-basierte Browser. Ach, die waren auch alle Webkit.
Die Geschichte von Webkit
ist ja, das ist eigentlich mal der KTML-Browser.
Ich glaube, das war auch... Conqueror war
KTML. Stimmt, stimmt.
Okay, was war ja das?
So.
Es gab mal ein paar
Gecko-basierte Browser. Es gab mal den
Chameleon-Browser, der sah aus wie Internet Explorer,
bloß dass er irgendwie gecko-basiert war.
Ich hab dir seit langem mal SeaMonkey benutzt. War das ein
Browser oder war das ein E-Mail?
SeaMonkey? Das war auch so ein Firefox-Klon.
Nee, das war das alte Mozilla.
SeaMonkey ist...
Weißt du, das ist das alte
Netscape. Warum muss ich dir diese Geschichte
erzählen? Ich vergesse Dinge.
Das fühlt mich alt.
Du weißt doch, wie...
Was Netscape alles für Features hatte. Das alte Netscape
Da war E-Mail drin, da war Chat drin,
das war eine Suite. Und als
Mozilla rauskam, dem ersten
Mozilla-Browser, was weiß ich, 1.0,
der dann Netscape 5
wurde, oder 6,
keine Ahnung, ich glaube, die hatten auch
eine Major-Version übersprungen.
Das war auch eine Suite, da war
das war der Browser, das war ein
E-Mail-Programm, dann gab es noch den Editor
drin, das war Web-
Visivic-Editor, der war da mit dabei.
du konntest optional noch dazu installieren
Chatzilla.
Und dann hattest du unten links
in deiner Statusleiste, konntest du durchschalten
und konntest du halt vom Browser direkt
im gleichen Fenster oder neues Fenster aufmachen.
Ich sag mal hier Fotos raus.
Mozilla 1.0 Suite.
Und das war alles in einem.
Und das lief ein paar Jahre.
Es hat nicht so wirklich groß geworden,
aber Netscape hat da seinen Netscape 5
oder sechs draus gemacht. Und irgendwann
haben sie gesagt, ja, aber es ist nicht so richtig lean.
Wir brauchen jetzt, wir machen jetzt einfach mal
aus unserem Stack was, was nur
Browser ist. Und das war dann
Phoenix. Und dann haben sie Phoenix
Firefox genannt. Ich hab
noch mitbekommen, es gab irgendwo Abstimmung,
wie wollen wir das Ding jetzt nennen?
Haben sich dann irgendwann für Firefox entschieden.
Wie sagen sie denn das jetzt Firefox?
Genau, und
die Mozilla Suite lief weiter.
Erst so noch als das Hauptprodukt und Firefox
Das kleine Nebending. Und Firefox
haben es dann immer schicker gemacht. Dieses kleine Ding, was eigentlich
nur Browser ist. Witzig.
Und ich habe auch Mozilla
weiter benutzt. Und irgendwann
haben sie gesagt, gut, das machen wir jetzt zu unserem Flagship.
Und dann machen wir jetzt
das Mail-Dings ziehen wir raus und machen
daraus eine eigene Mail-Anwendung. Das war dann Thunderbird.
Das haben sie einfach was aufgespalten.
Die haben es ein bisschen modularisiert.
Haben irgendwie Zool-Runner drunter gepackt.
Diese ganze UI war ja in Zool.
Im Zool-Thema hier.
Haben wir über Zool schon?
Ja, das ist ein paar Folgen her,
aber da haben wir schon mal wirklich... Genau.
Und die Original
Mozilla Suite haben sie dann in
Sea Monkey umbenannt.
Ach so. Das war das Original
Dings. Also das
ursprüngliche. Das war aber auch viel zu fett.
Also ich weiß noch,
wie sahen das? Oh, ist hier, gell mal.
Da siehst du so ein Bildschirm. Ein Screenshot von
Phoenix 01. Das war so
einer der ersten Firefox-Bilds auf Windows XP.
Geil. So einem Theme.
Also es ist
Solche Icon-Teams habe ich damals auch immer verwendet.
Genau. Und dann hast du
hier, das hier kennst du vielleicht, das ist
ein Podcast super,
wenn wir einfach random Screenshots anschauen.
Also sucht mal nach SeaMonkey,
beziehungsweise nach Mozilla 1.0, dann
seht ihr einfach eine Dark-Dak-Go-Bildersuche.
Genau, dadurch, dass das ja hier nicht
gefilterbabbelt ist,
solltet ihr ein möglichst vergleichbares
Econismus zu mir finden.
Aber ich meine,
so sah das aus,
das hat am Anfang noch die Icons, die aussahen,
wie bei Netscape.
Sah ein bisschen fetter aus, aber
und seitdem ist, aber von dem ist
glaube ich insgesamt nicht mehr viel übrig in der Codebase.
Diese Zeiten. Krass, krass.
Ja, ich weiß noch, dass ich irgendwie
als Mozilla 1.0
rauskam, habe ich eine halbe
Stunde lang den Installer runtergeladen
zu Hause. Das waren irgendwie so
9 Megabyte oder sowas.
Und dann eine Dreiviertelstunde runtergeladen
und dann habe ich sie auf CD gebrannt und meinem
Kumpel auf dem Schulhof mitgebracht.
Krass
Als der mir das ursprünglich vorgestellt hat
Das war der Kugel von mir, der mich überhaupt
an Computerprogramming
reingeführt hat, hat gesagt
Das ist cool, das ist ein Browser, den kannst du dir installieren
Der ist so klein
Da musst du nicht mal dein Betriebssystem neu starten
Wenn das installiert hat
Weil man ja irgendwie gefühlt bei Windows
jedes Mal, wenn du das installiert hast, das System neu starten
Du hast ja schließlich ein Programm installiert
Ist ja richtig so
Finde ich ja noch sinnvoll so, mache ich immer noch
immer neu starten. Nach jedem
Tassendruck neu starten.
Ich installiere mein System,
ich starte mein System echt nie neu.
Wenn ich jetzt mal hier so,
machen wir mal ein Experiment. Ihr macht jetzt mal bitte
alle Up-Time auf eurer
Konsole und sagt mir mal bitte,
wie lange euer System schon läuft.
Mestens fünf Tage, aber das nur, weil ich mit der Catalina-Beta-Duel-Boote
aktuell und...
Also mein Laptop läuft jetzt
seit 42 Tagen passenderweise?
Sowas hatte ich auch schon mal. Also generell,
so ein Monat ist normalerweise auch so Standard.
bis man halt doch irgendwie ein Systemupdate bekommt,
was Neustarter vorhat.
Ich esse es, habe ich mal an meinen PC da drüben rein
und mache mal Uptime auf der Kiste.
Die läuft erst seit elf Tagen.
Aber das ist halt ein Arch und jedes Mal
bei Arch kriegst du halt zwischendurch
immer mal bei den Updates auch
Kernel-Updates und ich habe irgendwie das Problem, wenn das
Kernel-Update kam
zwischendurch mal, dann funktionieren bei mir
Peripheriegeräte nicht mehr.
Ach so. Das heißt, wenn ich dann
USB-Stick oder sowas ranstecke, wird der irgendwie nicht mehr gemountet.
Das ist so eines, da brauche ich nicht mehr.
Ah ja, was habe ich für eine Uptime?
Oh, 200 Tage. Da wird irgendwo zwischendurch mal ein
Kernel-Update gewesen sein.
Genau.
Und der PC, den ich daneben,
der Laptop, den ich daneben liegen habe,
der läuft irgendwie, den habe ich 2012 installiert,
als ich mir den geholt habe und seitdem nie geupdatet.
Deswegen, man sagt immer,
Arch-Linux-Nutzer kennen sich viel mehr mit Linux aus,
weil irgendwie Arch-Linux zu installieren so hart ist.
Aber im Gegensatz zu so einem
Ubuntu musst du es nicht einmal im halben Jahr neu installieren.
deswegen hast du da Installationen, die da
8-9 Jahre stabil drauf laufen
und deswegen
kennen sich Artstellungsnutzer, wenn sie
sich ständig mal neue Rechner holen, eigentlich
überhaupt nicht gut mit installieren aus, weil
es einfach immer schon so lange her ist
und da hat es dann auch Spaß neu zu installieren
das kann man doch häufiger machen. Der hatte irgendwie Probleme
beim Neustarten, deswegen habe ich mich nicht mehr getraut,
den neu zu starten, dann hatte ich dann irgendwann so 1,5
Jahre Runtime so.
Das geht in mich an so ein altes
Projekt, was im Fachschaftsrat mal existierte
das war so ein Ding, um so
Lehrevaluationsdaten auszuwerten
und das ist auch so ein Tool, was irgendwie aus dem SVT-Projekt
mal hervorging, wo so Studenten
das Uni-Projekt programmiert haben und
das lief halt in so einer XPVM,
die aber nicht neu gestartet werden durfte.
Das heißt, diese XPVM wurde halt immer pausiert und
resumt, wenn sie jemand haben brauchte.
Ich weiß nicht, aber dann wird halt nicht mehr gelaufen.
Wurde mir so gesagt, ich hab die halt auch nie neu gestartet.
Ja, nie neu gestartet und wir trauen uns jetzt auch nicht.
Ich hab die drei Jahre lang, einmal im Jahr
für zehn Minuten gestartet
und danach immer halt wieder
das ist die VM eingefroren und ein Jahr später
wieder aufgeweckt. Naja, ich meine, heutzutage schippen wir
Anwendungen, indem wir die in Docker-Container
tun und da ist deine Anwendung quasi
das ist gar nicht mehr so weit weg davon.
Wir sind state-end fest committed, aber
so works on my machine, okay, we ship your machine
so ist doch kein Stand.
Oh man.
Ich glaube, wir sollten heute auch mal da gelangt, dass es am Ende kommen wurde.
Na, haben wir irgendwie
alle unsere Notizen durch?
Was ich noch habe hier ist, ich war vor ein paar Tagen
mal wieder auf dem Open Data Meetup,
was jetzt seit ein paar gefühlte
Jahre immer wieder stattgefunden hat.
Ich will ja niemandem vorwerfen, aber es war cool, dass es immer wieder stattgefunden hat.
Vor allem, weil auch die Stadt angekündigt
hat, jetzt hier ein Open Data Portal zu launchen.
Und das ist jetzt gekommen
und es wirkt etwas
enttäuschend, muss ich sagen, aber vielleicht habe ich es auch noch nicht...
Ja, du bist einfach mit der UI nicht zufrieden,
aber ich meine, da sind doch tonnenweise Daten drin, die
cool sind, oder?
Wie heißt die Seite? Mal schauen, hier
opendata.dresden.de
3D3 ausgeschrieben. Was ist das, was ich nicht
das weglässt? Das 3D weglässt?
opendata.dresden.de
Wäre ich wahrscheinlich
nach 3D weitergeleitet. Ja.
Guck mal, kurz so ein Text, der aussieht, als ob mir die Weiterleitung
nicht funktioniert hätte.
Was steht da, wenn ich der Escape drücke?
Zack, ah ne. Offene Daten für Dresden.
Wenn sie nicht weitergeleitet werden, klicken sie hier.
Da müssen wir mal ein bisschen durchschauen,
was hier eigentlich ist. Ich sehe sehr, sehr viel verlegte
CSV-Dateien.
Das ist ja auch der erste Stand hier
von dem Ding. Bevölkerung nach Geborene.
Aber ich gehe mal aus, dass sich von der UI her
nicht wirklich was ändern.
Wenn ich jetzt auf diese CSV,
dann kann ich diese CSV-Datei runterladen.
Gibt es da auch einfach einen Endpunkt,
wo ich mir die aktuell...
Ja gut, also das kann man mal erforschen.
Da gibt es,
da ist öffentliche Verwaltung,
Haushalt und Steuern.
Cool.
Mich würde mal interessieren, wer dieses Portal aufgesetzt hat.
Das sind bestimmt auch ganz coole Leute, oder?
Das ist die Firma...
Warte.
Das kann ich dir sogar sagen.
Wie heißen die?
EBIT,
die das machen für die Stadt.
Okay.
Kennst du die?
Ich meine, auf dem Open Data Meetup waren tatsächlich
eine Frau von denen da, die das Projekt
managt oder leitet oder irgendwie sowas.
Und zwei von der Stadt.
Oder einer von der Stadt irgendwie.
Und die haben das mit so ein bisschen
gesagt, die launchen das in den nächsten Tagen
und jetzt ist sie da.
Und ja,
wir wollten mal reinschauen, aber
irgendwie bin ich etwas underwhelmed,
aber wie gesagt, das ist
Version 0.1,
hier mal schauen.
Ich meine, immerhin gibt es ja auch eine Karte von
VR-Hotspots in der Stadt, das ist ja interessant.
Nee,
muss man mal reinschauen.
Ich verlinke es auf jeden Fall mal in den Journalisten,
wenn ihr Bock habt, mal reinzuschauen.
Das ist auch mal so eine Sache, die wollen halt auch immer Feedback dazu
und zwar ist mal das Thema
auf dem Meetup eigentlich, Feedback zu daten.
Und da gibt es
natürlich einen Feedback-Button,
wäre das eine, aber
die haben sich, glaube ich, ein bisschen komplizierter gedacht.
Es wäre ja schön, wenn es mehr als eine E-Mail
im Impressum gibt, sondern wenn es
irgendwo einfach ein Mail-To-Link ist, reicht das ja schon
als Feedback-Button.
Aber es muss natürlich auch jemand lesen und
bestenfalls antworten.
Sehe ich schon ein.
Hast du einen GitHub-Star?
Ich habe tatsächlich keinen einzigen.
Das tut mir sehr leid.
Ich habe nichts Neues gestarrt.
War so viel los?
Wie schaut es bei dir so aus?
Also ich würde tatsächlich mal
diesen Panorama View
empfehlen, packe ich in die Shownotes.
Das ist quasi das alte
Tab-Panorama
in Form von
als
Web-Extension. Das sieht zumindest
auf dem Screenshot hier, dem alten Tab-Panorama,
sehr, sehr ähnlich. Das ist sehr
schön. Und dann noch ein
Projekt, auf das man tatsächlich ein Auge werfen könnte,
ist Entropic. Und Entropic
ist der,
ist diese neue verteilte
Registry, die auf der
JSCon vorgestellt wurde. Die wird tatsächlich,
also die beiden Leute, die da dran maßgeblich arbeiten,
sind Leute, die vorher, kurz
vorher bei NPM waren und dann da ausgestiegen sind.
Also die hat, die das
vorgestellt hat, die CJ
Silverio hat gesagt, ja, also
ich arbeite jetzt mit dran und
wie ist denn der andere Typ, der das macht?
Den folge ich auch seitdem auf Twitter.
Tue ich in die Schauen, das habe ich vergessen.
Der hatte quasi auch bis vor ein paar Wochen noch bei NPM gearbeitet.
Dementsprechend hat er auch erst direkt,
nachdem er bei NPM aufgehört hat, angefangen,
an diesem Ding mitzuarbeiten,
weil es nicht gleichzeitig machen durfte, natürlich.
Und dementsprechend ist es noch relativ jung.
Aber behaltet das mal im Auge.
Der hatte irgendwie dann, als die den Vortrag gehalten hatten,
war das so ein bisschen der Launch davon,
obwohl es halt noch längst nicht Primetime ist.
Und das hatte der halt live irgendwie mitgeguckt.
hat dann hinterher auch drüber getwittert und plötzlich
hatten die beide irgendwie
100.000 Follower mehr. Keine Ahnung.
Und da hat er auch gemeint, ja,
Entropy produces
static, hatte er gepostet,
and Entropic produces
static assets.
Haha, I said
four weeks on that pun and now I finally post it.
Oh Mann, aber schön.
Ja, das ist so die Empfehlung.
Ansonsten dieses Mal eine etwas ruhigere Folge,
nachdem wir das letzte Mal so viel über Politik geredet haben.
Eigentlich haben wir uns versäumt,
uns mal Gäste einzuladen, weil wir hatten ja
irgendwie schon mehrere Male, wir sollten wahrscheinlich
nicht drüber reden, wenn wir es dann nicht wirklich machen.
Stimmt.
Also versuchen wir mal vielleicht beim
nächsten Mal, jetzt haben wir gerade so ein Jubiläum,
diese Folge.
30.
31. Akronomisierbar-Folge.
Mit der 0.
Stimmt, die 0. Nummer steht noch.
Das letzte war eigentlich das Jubiläum.
Verkackt.
Gut, müssen wir uns nochmal planen.
Währenddessen schreien uns hier die Swifts ins Ohr.
Na gut.
Dann bedanken wir uns,
dass ihr ein bisschen hier durchgehalten habt.
Auch wieder anderthalb Stunden Aufnahme.
Nicht schlecht.
Das nächste Mal vielleicht mit Gast mal gucken.
Das verspricht.
Wir sollten es nicht mehr versprechen.
Aber das nächste Mal.
Nee, wäre cool.
Wäre auf jeden Fall cool.
Genau.
Und das war jetzt
akonomisierbar 030.
Vorbei von Berlin.
Und der nächste Podcast
in eurem Podcatcher beginnt in
1, nee, 3.
Fuck.
Komm doch mal, du hast es heute nicht so
mit Zahlen.
3, 2, 1.
Bieb.